sortie est ce que c'est bien parti
alors go est ce que
je pense que c'est bon je ne sais
absolument pas je ne sais oui oui c'est
vrai par un je vois je vois je vois des
joies des commentaires donc c'est qu'on
sait c'est parti bon alors bonsoir à
tous et à toutes
à moins que ce ne soit à toutes et à
tous et désolé pour ce petit cafouillage
de départ qui est dû à la préhension
imparfaite des nouvelles technologies
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition
d'un facebook là il va et on va
directement commencé avec les quelques
questions que vous avez eu l'amabilité
de me poser alors je vais prendre comme
tout bon démagogue qui se respecte celle
qui a recueilli d'abord le plus de
suffrages
donc la première question c'est non pas
donc je vais d'abord faire une toute
petite remarque puisqu'il se trouve que
s'était posté sur sa page facebook ce
matin sur le le portrait de reporter
alors je faire un une remarque plus
large quelques précisions la première
précision c'est que je ne suis jamais
candidat à un portrait je trouve que
c'est un exercice journalistique
à titre personnel j'apprécie pas c'est à
dire que je ne lis pas les pensées des
autres oies très polis porte à d autres
jeux maintenant que je suis un tout
petit peu le côté de la barrière je
trouve que ça les inconvénients suivant
le premier c'est que ça crée de la
distance entre la personne qui est
l'objet d'un portrait et les gens avec
qui elle travaille ça crée un effet non
désirée de starisation
et du coup c'est inconfortable pour moi
cet exercice là c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je suis pas du tout
candidat parce que ça a conduit à ce que
les collaborateurs avec lesquels je
travaille
me voient sous un oeil un peu différent
un peu plus lointain un peu un peu plus
en plus quelqu'un venant du quotidien
quoi
voilà c'est un inconvénient comme tous
les inconvénients c'est rare qu'on court
après la deuxième la deuxième raison
pour laquelle je suis pas du tout
candidat c'est que ça prend du temps
alors prendre du temps pour un exercice
qui vous paraît pertinent c'est toujours
agréable prendre du temps pour un
exercice qui vous paraît moins
pertinents ben vous le faites entrer
dans un peu plus la pâte et puis vous
avez toujours deux options la première
c'est au contact en disant je vais faire
un portrait alors est ce que vous dites
aux journalistes doit ça m'intéresse pas
à bercy bien au risque de vous retrouver
avec des commentaires assassins ou bien
vous lui dites bon ben on voit très bien
par le nous et à ce moment vous y passer
une heure deux heures et vous vous dites
bon j'y passe une heure deux heures
parce qu'il faut mais enfin vous rangez
presque ça dans la catégorie de la
déclaration d'impôt et ça vous excite un
peu moins que des trucs un peu plus
rigolo la troisième chose c'est que bien
évidemment ne vous fait pas relire avant
parution ce qu'on s'apprête à raconter
sur vous donc si jamais il ya des choses
qui vous semblent ils exacte et rené et
c'est la seule possibilité que vous avez
7 corrigé après coup mais ça n'a jamais
la porte est en général de la de la
publication initiale et c'est rare que
vous soyez d'accord avec la totalité de
ce qu'on raconte sur vous pour de bonnes
ou de mauvaises raisons
du reste voilà donc c'était juste pour
dire que
c'est pas c'est pas du tout hein c'est
pas du tout un exercice dont je suis
friand passe très bien je considère que
ça n'apporte pas grand chose
je préfère de très loin les interviews
alors auquel on peut aussi reprocher de
starisé entre guillemets la personne
concernée enfin au moins ça permet
d'exprimer du fonds et par à quel âge
est la première dans quelle est ma
taille de chaussures ou la dernière fois
que je me suis raté leurs alliés donc
c'est quelque chose qui permet de
discuter un peu plus du message et un
peu moins du messager et pour finir
là-dessus savoir ce que j'ai fait il ya
40 ans je sais pas si c'est totalement
si c'est très utile pour savoir pour
rebondir par exemple sur une question à
laquelle j'aurai le plaisir de répondre
dans pas longtemps
est-ce qu'il faut mettre plus d'argent
ou moins d'argent dans la replantation
de veille en france
je ne sais pas si c'est essentiel de
savoir ce que j'ai fait il ya 40 ans
voilà donc c'était juste une petite
insiste pour commencer sur cet exercice
et il s'agit pas de répondre aux
arguments qui ont été évoqués c'est pas
nous c'est pas le but du jeu c'était
juste de faire un commentaire général
sur ce sur ce genre de choses
alors voilà maintenant d'entre eux
passeront en question est donc la
première question c'est est-ce que le
chip project va commenter les programmes
des candidats aux prochaines
présidentielles
alors la réponse est indirectement oui
même si c'est pas exactement ça qu'on va
faire alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est
indirectement oui parce que
vous le savez probablement pour un
certain nombre d'entre vous le chi
project s'est lancé dans un projet
pardon pour la répétition qui consiste à
proposer quelque part notre programme
alors je vais pas dire idéal mais nous
semblons intéressant à discuter si on si
on veut rester dans le positif
un programme environnemental aux socialo
économique nous semblait pertinent pour
les prochaines présidentielles
c'est ça qu'on appelle le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
et c'est ce sur quoi travaille en ce
moment d'arrache-pied un certain nombre
de gens dont peut-être certains qui vont
écouter ce qui suit alors ce plan ils
sont au moment où on en fera la
promotion ce qui a déjà commencé
il s'inscrira nécessairement sais pas si
je veux dire en contrepoint met enfin en
comparaison des propositions qui sont
déjà faites par un certain nombre de
candidats ou qui seront faites par un
certain nombre de candidats
donc oui on sera peut-être amené à
commenter des programmes mais pas à les
commenter
dans l'absolu aller commenté j'ai envie
de dire en différentiel par rapport à ce
que propose le chip project et ça sera à
ce moment nécessairement des
commentaires entre guillemets technique
entre guillemets sur le fond et pas des
commentaires qui seront machin il a une
tête qui me revient où il était qui me
revient pas justement on essaiera peut
pas tomber dans ce travers la et essayer
de se limiter aux commentaires sur le
fond c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on pense
de telles propositions exprimées de
manière très précise
par exemple je prends un exemple très
peu dans l'actualité
pas plus tard que ce matin hier matin je
ne sais plus il ya eu une dépêche aef
qui citait fa qui mentionnait le fait
que les républicains venaient de publier
leur programme environnemental pour les
prochaines présidentielles donc j'ai
regardé et je vais vous citer une
démesure il ya un juste pour donner il
propose d'allonger la durée légale de
garantie sur les appareils numériques
2 à 4 ans bon ben voilà typiquement un
truc personnellement je pense que ça va
dans la bonne direction
donc je dis ça va dans la bonne
direction le chiffre le dira ça va dans
la bonne direction mais quand la france
insoumise avait déposé une proposition
de loi il ya quelques semaines à
l'assemblée nationale en proposant de
porter la durée légale de garantie à 10
ans eh bien je dis tout autant savoir
aussi dans cette direction
donc on aura pas d'appréciation
partisane on essaiera vraiment
d'apprécier les mesures au fond à chaque
fois qu'on ferait un commentaire sur une
mesure environnementale
ça va être ça le ça va être ça l'idée
est ce qu'on fera des commentaires sur
d'autres mesures
la réponse est non ou plus exactement
dès lors qu'elles sortent du champ qui
se rattache directement aux questions
d'environnement en certes les questions
d'environnement son large puisque la
physique est un peu partout mais il ya
un certain nombre de propositions qui
relève totalement de considérations
morales religieuses de valeurs
sociétales et c'est sur lesquels laon
s'exprimera par je vais prendre un
exemple délibérément emblématique
si l'un des candidats proposent jeu
pourquoi de mettre un menu halal dans
les cantines balancer un avis ou n'aura
pas d'avis là dessus ni pour ni contre
ça sera hors champ des commentaires si
quelqu'un prend voilà donc les où je pas
oubli ou les où les propositions
en ce moment il ya un débat par exemple
sur la majorité pour le consentement
sexuel ça c'est typiquement une
proposition sur laquelle on sera hors
champ du débat c'est pas d'autres sujets
et on s'invite sera pas là dessus voilà
donc le mais par contre si un parti à
une proposition sur la manière de
réguler le commerce international là
probablement que on s'autorisera
éventuellement avoir un avis dessus
parce qu' il peut y avoir un lien direct
avec les questions environnementales
voilà donc on essaiera d'avoir une
grille de lecture si jamais on commente
des propositions qui sera la grille de
lecture qui est la nôtre c'est à dire
celle du de deux limites des limites de
la biosphère et des limites de la
planète mais à l'intérieur de ses
limites
on reste agnostique j'ai envie de dire
parce que ça relèvera de critères de
jugement qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
de notre ressort et sur lesquels
j'estime qu'on n'a pas un cadre il ya
enfin en tout cas pas en tant qu'entité
chi project après chacun est renvoyé à
ses choix à ses choix personnels
voilà donc c'est donc donc encore une
fois on va on va de temps en temps
commenté on ne va pas strictement
stricto sensu il noté donc pour si la
question était est ce que vous allez
nous donner pour chaque candidat une
note de 20 à 20 de telle sorte que ça va
nous ôter lépine du pied de savoir pour
qui on vote la réponse est dans fera pas
ça
ou en tout cas à chaud où j'ai envie de
vous dire que cette personne a dû
supporter ça m'excite pas plus que ça
comme idée d'abord parce que encore une
fois le côté environnemental et en
mettre en balance
d'autres valeurs et d'autres d'autres
sujets qui sont portées par les
candidats ensuite parce qu'il faut bien
voir que une proposition c'est à date et
qu'il ya des gens qui sont susceptibles
de changer d'avis
voilà donc on vote toujours pour quelque
chose d'hybride entre un individu et un
programme et enfin parce que ça nous
demanderait un boulot que l'on n'a juste
pas le chanteur qui consiste à commencer
à mettre un barème comme pour un examen
est ensuite corrigé toutes les copies
c'est sera suffisamment occupé avec ce
qu'on fait de notre côté sur ce plan de
transformation
donc on ne dompte oui on va
nécessairement se positionner de
l'andeva et puis on va faire la symétrie
cpt c'est à dire qu'on va bien
évidemment essayer de faire en sorte que
les candidats se positionne sur notre
programme donc j'ai envie de dire que
c'est surtout ça le but du jeu c'est
patent de doter ce qu'ils vont faire eux
c'est plutôt que eux essaye de repérer
ce qu'on a proposé nous et idéalement de
se positionner afin de s'en inspirer ou
de se positionner par rapport à ça c'est
plutôt ça notre notre ambition et notre
objectif est donc les critiques et
gentiment est factuellement où les
critiques et manière constructive on
s'le autorisera 6 a conduit à les
crisper probablement que on le fera part
parce que le but du jeu c'est pas de
décrisper c'est vraiment de les faire
progresser
voilà le voilà ce que je pouvais dire
sur cette question de la notation ou pas
des programmes
alors est-ce qu'à des politiques ou des
décideurs qui partage votre vision du
monde même s'il sait qu'en off alors
j'imagine que la la la réponse à cette
question est oui alors dans votre vision
du monde je sais pas si je dois la
prendre comme la vision du shift ou la
vision de jancovici
d'aucuns d'aucune mauvaises langues
diraient c'est la même chose
pas tout à fait parce que pour renvoyer
à la première partie de ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure sur le portrait le shift
c'est aujourd'hui pas loin de 30
permanents
c'est pas loin de dix mille bénévoles je
ne pense pas que toute cette diversité
soit réductible à ma propre pensée et
heureusement et c'est une très bonne
chose
donc ça me gênerait que qu'il en soit
ainsi
donc je hais est du reste j'en profite
pour dire une chose en passant qu'il
paraît essentiel quand des gens me
manifestent leur soutien
en réponse à des critiques je les invite
vraiment mais alors vraiment à rester
tout le temps cordiaux constructif et
factuel donc il ne renvoie très mauvais
service
je sais pas s'il s'en rendre compte s'il
commence à devenir radicaux excessif
insultes en injuriant etc même si de
temps en temps je trouve ça désagréable
il m'arrive de exactement je trouve
désagréable de devoir me contenir parce
qu on est tous pareils de temps en temps
on a un peu envie de répondre du tac au
tac
j'essaye de me m'astreindre à vis
discipline qui est de ne jamais répondre
autrement que sur le fond quand je fais
l'objet d' attaque qui mélange le fond
et la forme
je suis un vendu je suis pas quoi je
suis un vendu donc je raconte des
conneries sur les déchets non si je
raconte des conneries sur les déchets je
regarde ce qu'on me reproche très
concrètement sur les déchets et si j'ai
un truc factuel à répondre je réponds et
je ne réponds pas à la partie attaques
personnelles eh ben je j'aimerais
vraiment que les gens qui n'ont pas
parle en mon nom parce que ça n'existe
pas mais qui répondent à des critiques
dont je fais l'objet essaye de
s'astreindre à cette discipline qui en
plus est très utile pour chacun parce
que ça permet de progresser qui est de
se limiter à la discussion sur le fond
en faisant abstraction de la forme voilà
je n'étais pas la réponse à la question
du tout mais je profite de cette danse
est pensé qu'il vient à l'esprit pour
vous partager ses réflexions
donc pour en revenir à la question de
des politiques et des décideurs qui
partagent notre vision du monde alors
vision du monde où la mienne en tout cas
il ya énormément de choses dedans
donc si dans ma vision du monde il ya le
fait que je préfère la couleur bleue à
la couleur orange
oui peut-être des gens qui partagent il
ya des gens qui partagent pas
mais voilà ça je le vois pas ce qu'on en
tire donc les éléments qui sont
importants
probablement dans cette discussion c'est
est ce que il ya un nombre significatif
de décideurs économiques ou de décideurs
politiques qui acceptent par exemple
l'idée qu' il faut disposer d'un plan
dans un monde sans conscience et bien la
réponse à ça c'est oui en tout cas oui
dans les échanges bilatéraux après il ya
ce qu'ils lisent en public il faut
savoir que les les personnages
politiques ont un côté très déroutant
que j'ai mis du temps à comprendre qui
est que quand on discute avec eux hors
caméra et or oreilles externe
on a l'impression d'avoir affaire à des
gens normaux et puis desquels caméra
quelque part il switch en mode en est à
ce moment c'est plus les mêmes individus
ils ont tous un côté docteur jekyll et
mister hyde qui est très déroutant ou
missy side qui est très déroutant canton
quand on n'est pas habitué
et donc ils peuvent dire l'exact inverse
de ce qu'ils vous ont dit en privé
parce que c'est ça qui va les valoriser
aux yeux des médias quand ils sont en
face de vous il faut le savoir
c'est c'est pas confortable mais c'est
comme ça donc en off et après quand
toute la question est de savoir ce qui
va primer entre ce qu'ils vous ont dit
en off dans leurs constructions leurs
discours et ceux qui pensent qu'ils
doivent dire quand ils sont en public
pour plaire à leurs électeurs ou se
ferment ou si c'est pas nécessairement
la même chose alors en off ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'il ya un nombre
croissant de personnages politiques ces
derniers temps avec qui il a été
possible de nouer le contact ou qui ont
été demandeurs de contact alors ça je
l'interprète non pas du tout comme le
fait qu'il trouve que tout d'un coup je
suis quelqu'un d'extraordinaire je pense
que je l'interprète comme le fait que le
la façon de voir les choses qui porté
par votre modeste serviteur et surtout
les structures dans lesquelles je suis
impliqué commence à monter ça commence
c'est quelque chose qui devant sa porte
et ça commence à avoir un peu d'audience
et donc du coup les gens qui veulent
être élus s'y intéresse parce qu'à
partir du moment où c'est susceptible de
représenter la vision d'une frange de
l'électorat
eh bien il est de leur devoir presque de
commencer à regarder ce qu'il ya
derrière donc des politiques qui
viennent vers moi ou des politiques avec
lesquelles il est répondu positivement
quand je leur propose de discuter il y
en a plus qu'à man dans le monde des
décideurs économiques
cette idée qu'on va probablement devoir
faire avec un univers sans croissance
est aussi quelque chose qui commence à
trouver un écho croissant pardon pour ce
conte pompiers et donc c'est aussi un ça
veut pas dire nécessairement que ils
vont ils vont demain matin changer
totalement la façon dont il fonctionne
on est tous prisonniers de nos habitudes
de nos rentes de nos situations acquises
de notre confort etc
même les gens qui se revendique
révolutionnaire en fait quand on regarde
bien
mais eux ont du mal de temps en temps à
s'abstraire d'une partie des habitudes
qu'il faudrait qu'ils abandonnent donc
le don qu'il faut toujours un peu se
méfier de la delà de la poutre dans son
propre rails avant d'aller voir la
paille chez les autres mais c'est en
tout cas il ya une facilité à discuter
de ce genre de sujet qui va croissant
dans le monde syndical commence
également à avoir des discussions qu'on
n'avait pas avant
et pas plus tard que ce matin j'ai eu
une discussion alors aggravé qui parce
que c'est prématuré mais avec un
dirigeant syndical et quand je me dis il
n'est pas exclu qu'il faille organiser
l'avenir avec une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat et la bonne question c'est de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on ne désespère
pas billancourt dans cette dent dans ce
monde là il m'a pas du tout volé dans
les plumes
il m'a dit qu'il faut il était
probablement assez d'accord même si ils
étaient payés pour défendre ses
adhérents mais que mais qu' il est
intellectuellement ce que je disais de
le choquer pas et donc je pense qu'il ya
une maturité chez en tout cas dans les
échanges bilatéraux il ya une maturité
qui est en train de venir chez certaines
personnes
c'est plutôt un signe d'espoir après la
question c'est de savoir ce qu'ils
arrivent à en faire dans un discours
public je le redis et des fois on a des
mauvaises surprises
c'est un des côtés très déroutant de
tous les gens qui sont en représentation
pour une partie de leur activité
professionnelle donc donc donc sur cet
élément là qui est que le monde est
contraint et fini qui est probablement
l'élément le plus structurant j'ai envie
de dire de ma pensée parce que c'est
après derrière ça en gros les deux
éléments structurants de la pensée c'est
que le monde est fini et qu'on est dans
une course contre la montre donc une
fois que j'ai dit c'est deux choses là
après une bonne partie de ce qu'on doit
faire en face de ça c'est des arbitrages
qui s'inscrivent dans ce cadre là si on
essaye de décembre un cran en dessous
dans il ya d'autres éléments sur
lesquels maintenant il commence à y
avoir des positions assez consensuel
dans les politiques par exemple le fait
qu'il faut s'occuper sérieusement du
patrimoine bâti
ça c'est quelque chose qui commence à
devenir assez consensuel par contre le
fait qu' il fallait dégonfler les
métropoles bayadh et il ya des gens dans
le monde politique qui comprennent
ménisque rooney ne souscrivent pas il ya
des gens qui comprennent même pas qu'ils
disent que c'est complètement idiot
puis il ya des gens qui disent que oui
effectivement c'est probablement ça
qu'il faut faire le même leader syndical
avec lequel je discutais ce matin m'a
dit exactement ça va il m'a dit qu'il
était d'accord avec ce point de vue
qu'il fallait maintenant dégonfler les
métropoles
reste à savoir comment on fait donc donc
donc pour résumer cette réponse
si la question est à comprendre sous
l'angle est ce qu'il ya un nombre
croissant de dirigeants économiques
politiques et syndicaux avec qui on peut
avoir des débats à peu organisés sur ces
questions là la réponse est oui ils sont
en nombre en nombre croissant
alors après il ya une question à
laquelle j'ai déjà répondu est ce que le
rapport sur la décarbonation de
l'économie française sera soumis aux
candidats de la présidentielle la
réponse est oui absolument
alors on va pas soumettre candidats en
fait les candidats ça les intéressera
cette affaire-là ci s'est soumis à leurs
électeurs avant quelque chose que j'ai
souvent l'habitude de dire c'est que on
intéresse un politique à partir du
moment où on arrive avec un triptyque
qui est un problème une solution et une
sanction pour le politique s'il ne met
pas en oeuvre la solution
en fait il faut les 3 donc si vous
arrivez juste avec un problème ça
n'intéresse personne cette personne est
intéressée avec des produits sans
solution non plus quelque part papa pas
tellement si on arrive avec un problème
mais une solution c'est déjà mieux
mais un politique pour lui la laverai et
j'ai envie de dire
l'élément qui vraiment importe c est ce
qu il va être élu ou pas et donc c'est
quelle est la sanction à mettre en
oeuvre la solution et quelle est la
sanction elle pas la mettre en oeuvre
dans les deux cas de figure en gros
qu'est ce qui va lui rapporter le plus
de voix est donc s'il pense que de ne
pas faire ce qu'on lui propose de faire
va lui faire perdre des voix parce qu'on
dira ailleurs tiens c'est intelligent et
une fraction significative de ses
électeurs dira ah oui effectivement chez
d'accord à ce moment-là il non seulement
il écoutera mais il sera un peu motivés
pour faire donc
et pour ça il faut avoir parlé aux
électeurs avant d'avoir parlé aux
candidats c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a mis en oeuvre depuis longtemps aux
chiffres project un dialogue avec les
corps intermédiaires
pourquoi avec les corps intermédiaires
alors c'est pas parce qu'on aime parler
qu'aux privilégiés qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans les cordes intermédiaire ses
dirigeants économiques les dirigeants
syndicaux le monde académique on va dire
et la haute fonction publique
alors c'est pas parce qu'on aime parler
qu'aux privilégiés qu'ont fait ça c'est
parce que quand on a des moyens limités
ce qui est le cadre du chiffre project
c'est là on à l'effet de levier maximum
parce que les corps intermédiaires c'est
à la fois des gens qui parlent à leurs
collaborateurs
et ça ça fait beaucoup de monde quand
vous êtes dirigeant d'entreprise vos
collaborateurs ça fait un paquet de
monde et c'est des gens qui parlent à
l'étagé au dessus ou qu'il ya un moyen
de pression à l'étagé au dessus c'est à
dire vers les politiques parce que ils
sont susceptibles peut-être pas de les
faire chanter mais enfin de leur
raconter des choses en disant qu'à
écouter s'il est ici si vous faites pas
peut-être truc qui paraît intelligent au
moins qui m'arrange plus exactement
eh bien je serais pas content je le fais
savoir donc c'est ça notre cible
historique au chief project et c'est
bien à cette cible là on destine en
priorité le plan de transformation
cette cible là on espère qu'ils vont
eux-mêmes relayer les propositions
encore une fois vers les gens qui sont
dans leur propre écosystème
donc si par exemple à des dirigeants
d'entreprise qui pense que nos
propositions sont intelligentes ou en
tout cas mérite examen
et bien immédiatement ça se répercute à
un nombre beaucoup plus important de
personnes
c'est vrai également avec la presse
voilà donc c'est ça le ca la première le
premier étage de l'édifice et c'est si
on passe cette trempe là que à ce moment
les candidats nous écoutent ou plus
exactement que leur état leur écurie de
campagne nous écoute parce que les
candidats eux mêmes ils ont ils ont des
gens à qui ils font confiance pour faire
des propositions
il rédige pas tout de même de voir
jusqu'à z
voilà alors il ya une question sur quel
parti politique vous semble plus
conscients
de linkedin etc tu la vis
l'inéluctabilité je vais y arriver des
catastrophes à venir et des actions à
mettre en oeuvre un joker je n'en ai pas
d'idées je ne sais pas ou plus
exactement si je regarde dans les partis
qui sont susceptibles de gagner des
élections parce que c'est finalement
cela qu'ils sont vraiment importants à
court terme je sais pas répondre à cette
question parce que ça dépend dans quelle
catastrophe on parle et ça dépend de ce
qu'on appelle être conscient du
caractère inéluctable et sa fin je sais
pas prête très honnêtement je ne suis
pas complètement sûr que pour le combat
du chiffres projet que ce soit très
important je pense qu'encore une fois
comme on est agnostique
sur le plan politique ben nous on parle
à tout le monde et puis ou en tout cas
on essaye d'infuser les électeurs de
tous quand c'est ça qui nous paraît
important et du coup notre action ne
nécessite pas d'avoir la réponse à cette
question que très honnêtement je n'ai
pas alors après une question sur le
rayonnement international
est ce que le chypre jette au carbone 4
ont des contacts avec les organismes des
entreprises en belgique au canada
dans le reste de la francophonie alors
la réponse est oui alors pas carbone4
carbone 4 je rappelle que c'est une
entreprise commerciale et qu'une
entreprise commerciale
elle a rarement pour objet de vous le 2
combien de militer pour une organisation
particulière de la société en dehors de
son champ de compétence directe donc on
reconnaît aux entreprises c'est ça qu'on
appelle le lobbying le sais pas si je
dois dire le droit mais enfin si une
certaine manière le droit au sens légal
du terme d' exprimer des points de vue
dans le domaine qui les concernent
directement de carbone 4 s'exprime dans
le champ de sa serait bien que les
méthodes soient faites comme ceux ci
plutôt comme cela dans le champ de ce
serait bien que les gens soient formés
comme ceux ci plutôt comme cela où
qu'ils soient formés pour voilà carbone4
s'exprime dans le champ de on vous
propose de l'information carbone4
s'exprime dans le champ en gros de ce
qui concerne directement son activité et
c'est une expression qui est largement
lié au propre destin de carbone cap
carbon qui est le cas de toutes les
entreprises bouix exprime assez peu
souvent sur la pêche à la baleine et je
sais pas orange s'exprime assez peu
en règle générale sur l'agriculture de
conservation des sols
alors que par contres invivo pourra le
faire donc le les entreprises en général
s'exprime sur ce qui est dans leur champ
d'activité direct c'est ça en général
quelle qu'elles font du coup il n'y a
pas chez carbone 4 un prosélytisme
organisé à l'échelle planétaire pour
aller toucher des contacts à l'extérieur
de la france pardon sauf si c'est
quelque chose qui est un préalable à son
activité
comme pour n'importe quelle entreprise
donc et c'est bien parce que le rôle de
carbone cac n'est pas celui d'une
association qu'il existe carbone 4 et
qu'il existe de chic project qui est
tout à fait différent et du reste les
deux autres associés de 44 ou tous les
deux des casquettes dans le monde
associatif pour être capable d'exercer
cette partie convictions de nos
concitoyens dans un cadre qui est bien
un cadre associatif est pas un cadre
d'entreprise donc alain grandjean il est
président de la fmh avec ce fondation
nicolas hulot et laurent morel qui est
troisième associé de 44 il est trésorier
du chic project et président de l'ifp
aib qui est une association qui s'occupe
de performance énergétique dans le
bâtiment
donc on a tous nos casquettes
associative en dehors de carbone 4 et
c'est essentiellement à ce titre que
l'on fait du prosélytisme
alors pour répondre maintenant à la
question en ce qui concerne le shit
project pas juste pour finir sur 44 ya
au sein de carbone 4 d'un certain nombre
de collaborateurs qui ont aussi des
activités de militant et l'essentiel du
temps ses activités de militant
s'exerce dans le cadre de structures qui
sont qui sont hors 44 donc des
associations éventuellement il y en a 1
carat mandat d'élu qui élu au conseil de
paris voilà c'est en dehors de en dehors
de carbone 4 que ça se passe et c'est
normal même si carbone 4 est une société
engagée en ce qui concerne et donc c'est
pour finir de répondre à ça les
entreprises qui vous disent moi je porte
atlas sur mes épaules et j'ai la charge
de sauver le monde vous raconte des
carabistouilles c'est pas vrai carbone
car tu n'as pas à sa charge de sauver le
monde et c'est bien pour ça que si on
est intéressé entre guillemets à sauver
le monde
on va s'investir dans des associations
ou dans des organismes dont ça se
rapproche du mandat explicite
alors le gie project qui a vocation
alors peut-être pas à sauver le monde
mais en tout cas à proposer des mesures
qui permettent de durer si c'est ça dont
on a envie et bien puisqu'on peut ne pas
en avoir envie et bien lui effectivement
il est comme toute association militante
intéressées à louer des contacts un dans
la sphère la plus large possible alors à
l'étranger ça ne passe pas directement
par le chiffre project c'est un passe
par une association cousine qui
s'appelle les shifters et qu'un certain
nombre de gens qui écoutent connaissent
très vraisemblablement puisque c'est
j'imagine qu'il y en a quelques-uns qui
écoutera ce moment alors c'est quoi
l'articulation entre les deux le chi
project est une association
d'entreprises donc les membres du chis
project ne peuvent être que des
entreprises s'est du reste quelque chose
qu'on peut nous reprocher parce que du
coup on peut nous dire qu'on n'est
inféodé au grand capital
c'est parfois ou plus exactement c'est
délibéré parce que le chip project a
essayé d'occuper la niche écosystémiques
qui est non par je rouspète de
l'extérieur mais j'essaye de faire de
l'entrisme à l'intérieur les deux sont
utiles donc je pense que quand oxfam
sort un rapport qui a lieu les banques
qui a vu le cac 40 c'est très utile mais
du coup c'est des interlocuteurs avec
lesquels les entreprises ont pas envie
de travailler et c'est normal parce que
c'est rare que vous ayez envie de
travailler avec des gens qui vous mettre
des baffes
il sait pas inutile d'avoir à côté de ça
des gens qui sont à l'intérieur et qui
peuvent prendre le relais ou qui peuvent
s'articuler ou qui peuvent de temps en
temps anticiper les bases qui vont venir
de l'extérieur et qui aide les
entreprises à progresser en en faisant
des choses qui sont plus appliquées j'ai
envie de dire parce que c'est plus lié à
des éléments techniques internes au
métier donc c'est ça le ce qu'on essaye
de faire au shift c'est de cesser non
pas d'occuper la place de
vous êtes une bande d'incapables et vous
n'avancez pas assez vite ce qui n'est
pas faux ou ce qu'il ya quelque chose de
vrai mais la niche qui est bon
maintenant admettons que vous ayez bien
entendu le message
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour essayer
d'avancer alors c'est une niche qui est
parfois plus ingrates
parce que on les marches d'escalier une
par une
on fait pas le grand soir dans ce genre
de dans ce genre de contexte
c'est plus donc c'est plus continue
c'est quelque chose qui par construction
emportements la révolution voilà c'est
un autre genre de beauté à titre
personnel je pense que c'est utile que
ça existe je ne revendique absolument
pas le fait que ça soit ça l'essentiel
de l'action pertinentes à faire encore
une fois je pense que les nuits ion
venant de l'extérieur est très utile
sinon indispensable mais je pense que ça
se complètent et qu'on a notre place
dans l'écosystème et que c'est utile que
que l'on fasse ce genre de choses donc
et une fois que le prendre le maître
d'école vous à distribuer des baffes en
disant vous êtes nuls
c'est pas lui qui va le mieux occuper la
position de celui qui prend l'enfant par
la main en lui disant écoute je vais
t'aider
je vais t'aider à faire mieux si tant
est sérieux donc nous c'est ça qu'on
essaye de faire au chiffre des saints
suppose pour tendre le parallèle de
prendre un enfant par la main d'avoir un
dialogue avec les entreprises donc ça
suppose de les faire venir et il ya un
truc qui est assez vrai dans le monde de
l'entreprise c'est qu'une bonne manière
de les faire venir c'est de les faire
payer parce que une fois que vous avez
payé quelque chose vous le respectez un
tout petit peu voilà donc ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas inutile de procéder de
cette manière mais pour le pour finir se
complètent donc le chiffre est une
association d'entreprises
à côté de ça il ya historiquement plein
de gens qui ont dit ben nous on aimerait
bien faire quelque chose pour la cause
et donc c'est créer à côté une
association qui s'appelle les shifters
alors le shift et les shifters marche la
main dans la main les shifters ont des
représentants conseil d'administration
du chiffre project lochies project a des
représentants dans ma pomme au conseil
d'administration des shifters en marche
ensemble les shifters non pas
d'expressions autonome
donc ils n'ont pas de communication
autonome sauf cas particulier mais sinon
ils n'en n'ont pas donc c'est vraiment
des individus qui sont en appui aux
chiffres project et qui sont coordonnés
avec le chip project c'est pas ça dit
pas sa vie totalement de son côté par
contre cette association a la
particularité comme c'est une
association de personnes de pouvoir
rallier du monde très rapidement dans
plein de pays dans le monde et donc on a
dit d'antenne via cette association en
belgique en suisse au canada dans toute
la sphère francophone on en a également
à l'ombre on en a également dans un
certain nombre d'autres villes en russie
en pologne
on en a pas de ce serment beaucoup à
chaque fois mais aimé y en a alors c'est
des gens qui sont évidemment très utile
parce qu'ils nous font des remontées de
ce qui se passe de leur côté ça permet
de savoir si on est capable nous le
shift d'amener de la valeur ajoutée dans
d'autres pays parce que on a pris un peu
d'avancé dans la façon de voir les
choses ça peut être utile aux gens du
pays du pays concerné c'est pas du tout
une vision colonialiste c'est juste que
de temps en temps il n'est pas interdit
d'aller piocher ailleurs une bonne idée
on fait suffisamment souvent avec les
mauvaises le faire aussi de temps encore
avec les bonnes donc qu on a déjà des
antennes dans une partie de la
francophonie
on n'en a pas encore beaucoup voire pas
du tout en afrique mais on y réfléchit
je parle bien de la francophonie et
c'est des gens avec qui on a des
interactions donc il ya pas très
longtemps que j'étais en visio avec les
shifters de montréal et pas plus tard
que demain je vais aller voir les
chiffres us belge
je vais franchir la fontière faire un
truc qui est qui et qui est une audace
folle qui est de reprendre le train pour
franchir une frontière et donc ces gens
là encore une fois c'est des gens sur
lesquels on peut s'appuyer pour étendre
notre attraction alors bruxelles
évidemment ça a un rôle particulier
parce que c'est à la fois la belgique en
tant que pays et puis c'est le siège de
la commission qui a quand même un tout
petit rôle dans le fonctionnement de
l'attelage européen donc bien évidemment
les shifters belge on compte s'appuyer
sur eux pour augmenter notre capacité de
lobbying
car je répète encore une fois que toute
personne qui cherche à peser sur le
débat public et d'un lobbyiste donc pour
renforcer notre capacité auprès des
instances européennes qui sont situés à
bruxelles et en particulier la
commission et parlement
voilà donc on
c'est la manière dont on s'exporte
aujourd'hui c'est essentiellement via
les shifter pour finir et revenir sur
carbone4 l'exportation via carbone 4
c'est la norme
donc en gros quand carbone 4 produits de
la norme ou des propositions de normes
et que sa rencontre de l'éco hors des
frontières
bah c'est la manière dont on s'exporte
alors on l'a fait plusieurs fois on l'a
fait enfin votre serviteur l'a fait avec
le bilan carbone puisque le bilan
carbone est devenu a servi de base à la
nomenclature de la norme iso qui fait
aujourd'hui qui porte sur l'empreinte
carbone d'une organisation et on est en
train d'essayer de réitérer ça dans
d'autres domaines là dans pas longtemps
on va sortir une méthode sur la manière
de d'évaluer les risques physiques du
changement climatique pour une
entreprise avec aussi une approche par
scop par processus et c'est exactement
comme pour le bilan carbone et dont on
espère bien que ça va éveiller
l'attention en dehors des frontières
voilà donc l'exportation de carbone 4
avant même d'être par les produits elle
est par la production de normes
ah ben voilà on parlait de carbone 4
comment faites vous pour avoir des
clients un quart 24 avec le discours que
vous tenez publiquement eh bien ça
répond pour partie à la question qui a
été posée tout à l'heure qui est ce
qu'il ya des gens avec qui il est
possible de discuter dans le monde des
décideurs économiques des sujets de fond
à la réponse est oui vous avez de temps
en temps alors il faut bien voir carbone
4 puisque les chiffres sont à peu près
public puisqu'ils sont dans l'arctique
de reporter
car votre cave tout mouillé aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près une centaine de
personnes carbone 4 c'est à la fois une
activité de conseil c'est une activité
de fourniture de données dans le monde
financier et une activité de formation
et c'est une activité d'empreinte
carbone personnel au travers de maïs ils
tous à tout mouillé ça fait 100
personnes avant vous vous direz sans
personne ça commence à faire beaucoup
oui oui ok pour sébastien bauler qui
prétend que femme qui prétend qui dit
j'ai pas du tout de manière désagréable
que la cervelle humaine est configuré
pour reconnaître 150 visage lui c'est
clair ça commence à faire beaucoup
[Musique]
maintenant pour compter les rien pour
compter les euros et rien qu'en france
rien qu'une boîte comme deloitte ses dix
mille personnes donc est-ce que c'est
beaucoup est-ce que c'est pas beaucoup
ça dépend ce qu'on a comme idée
moi je considère que à l'échelle de
l'économie française c'est très très peu
donc à l'échelle de l'économie française
en fait un discours quel qu'il soit
trouvent preneurs je connais des gens
qui vendait du conseil en expliquant que
les modèles climatiques raconter
n'importe quoi
je connais des gens qui vendent du
conseil ou plus exactement des conseils
aux particuliers en expliquant qu'ils
vont lire leur avenir dans le marc de
café donc fall je veux dire comme je dis
pas que 44 lits sont à venir dans le
marc de café et nous le marc de café on
met à la poubelle de recyclage mais
c'est juste pour dire que en fait la
radicalité du discours on est né d'un
obstacle qu'en apparence parce que quel
que soit le discours sur la masse vous
trouverez toujours quelques personnes
qui y adhèrent
donc le fait que le discours semble
radical en fait paradoxalement c'est pas
nécessairement un quelque chose qui vous
empêche d'avoir des clients
la bonne question c'est est-ce que la
radicalité du discours cantonne à une
toute petite frange de clientèle en fait
c'est ça la bonne question est bien le
mon sentiment c'est que de moins en
moins parce qu on a quand même dans ce
pays un certain nombre de gens qui
savent compter
on a quand même dans ce pays un certain
nombre de gens pas tous évidemment passé
mais quand même un certain nombre de
gens qui réalise qu'il ya des évolutions
en cours
il ya quand même un certain nombre de
gens qui sont à même de comprendre
et de réfuter donc de se faire leur
propre avis sur ce qu'on peut raconter
et ces gens là bas ils sont après libre
d'avoir envie de travailler avec carbone
4 par ailleurs il faut bien voir que
carbone 4 ne vend pas le discours de
jean marc jancovici carbone car devant
des méthodes vendée analyses etc et donc
il n'est pas du tout exclu qu'il y ait
au sein de carbone 4 encore une fois
sans personne ne s'est pas du tout moi
qui fais est loin s'en faut
l'essentiel des contacts commerciaux et
l'essentiel des missions
il n'est pas du tout exclu je suis même
sûr qu'il y en a au sein de carbone
cadre des gens qui disent je travaille
avec vous enfin qu'ils disent mes
collaborateurs je travaille avec vous
parce que ce que vous allez me faire
dans le cadre de ce que je vais vous
demander va être de bonne qualité mais
ce que vous racontez votre patron par
ailleurs je suis pas sûr d'y souscrire
je sais parfaitement possible qu'il y
ait ça j'ai pas posé la question mais
c'est tout à fait possible donc 44
devant pas un discours je répète carbone
car devant d analyse des méthodes et des
des réponses à des questions combien de
frigo est ce qu'on peut continuer à
vendre en 2050 dans un monde à deux
degrés est ce que pour répondre à cette
question vous avez besoin de souscrire à
ce que raconte jancovici sur
l'agriculture bio ou sur le vélo la
réponse est donc pas besoin d'y
souscrire
c'est totalement à côté on s'en fout
donc ce que je dis ne pèse pas
nécessairement très lourd face à la
capacité à répondre à la question posée
que je viens d'évoquer ce qui ce qui me
paraît être un meilleur juge de paix
plus que carbone 4 si je peux me
permettre un une réflexion incidente
c'est le l'audience dans les réseaux
professionnels
alors il ya un thermomètre que je trouve
intéressant à regarder ces linkedin
linkedin rassemble probablement des gens
qui en termes de catégories
socioprofessionnelles me ressemble c'est
à dire plutôt des cars pour l'essentiel
est la nature des commentaires la nature
des engagements est pour moi un test de
est-ce que l'argumentaire semble
recevable ou pas dont hélas j'ai envie
de penser si j'en juge par le nombre que
la tendance est plutôt à un nombre
croissant de gens qui pensent qu'il ya
un sujet plutôt qu'à un nombre
décroissant
alors encore une fois après quelqu'un
qui éveille la curiosité sur un sujet
vous n'êtes pas nécessairement vais pas
nécessairement besoin d'être d'accord
avec lui surtout pour travailler avec
lui vous pouvez juste pensé que
vous en aurez pour votre argent point
c'est à dire que la réponse à la
question vous amènera une valeur ajoutée
qui est au moins égale à la facture
payée c'est pas dans le monde économique
et un certain nombre de gens qui sont
assez triviaux comme certains qui
regardent le savent peut-être voilà et
après s'il ya des questions
bon après on va passer à des questions
qui sont différentes
je suis désolé et j'espère qu'on la lise
est question et puis je regarde celles
qui ont re qui ont reçu le plus de
suffrages donc on va passer à quelque
chose qui n'a rien à voir la question
est libellé de la manière suivante jmj
at il explicité son point de vue sur
l'agriculture biologique les éléments
qui l'ont conduit à adopter ce point de
vue alors qu'est ce que j'ai comme point
de vue sur l'agriculture biologique bas
avant de parler d'agriculture biologique
je vais parler de mon point de vue sur
l'agriculture tout court
l'agriculture tout court aujourd'hui est
une des quatre ou cinq activités qui ont
besoin des sols pour fournir quelque
chose qui est un tout petit peu
nécessaire pour le métabolisme y en un
qui s'appelle la nourriture
cette agriculture est en concurrence
avec quelques autres usages alors les
autres usages sont la biodiversité c'est
à dire qu'on ne touche pas au sol et on
laisse entre guillemets la nature s'en
emparer avec toutes les petites bêtes et
les plantes qui vont avec
il ya un usage qui est un usage
énergétique
je me sers des surfaces pour faire
pousser du bois ou des cultures
énergétiques dont je vais avoir besoin
pour alimenter mes machines
il y à un usage qui est celui des
infrastructures
donc je me sers du sol pour y mettre des
routes ou des parkings de supermarché et
puis il ya un dernier usage qui est
celui du matériau donc je me sers du sol
pour faire pousser du chanvre du lin
pour le chant vont pas pour le tuer
du lin ou du bois mais comme matériau
cette fois ci pas comme énergie donc le
sol
il est temps il est temps il est en
quantité limitée et il le début de
l'entonnoir c'est que l'agriculture est
un
une des manières d'occuper ce sol à
chaque fois que la production de
nourriture identique on est capable de
mieux préserver notamment la
biodiversité
eh bien j'ai envie de me dire que on a
plutôt deux usages en 1 plutôt qu'un
seul usage donc tout ce qui permet
d'aller dans le sens d'une agriculture
qui mal traitement à la biodiversité est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse maintenant
il faut bien voir que l'agriculture est
par essence même une suppression de la
biodiversité c'est à dire que dans un
champ anglais ce qui vous intéresse et
qui pousse doublé lille vous intéresse
pas qu'il plonge du trèfle ni qui
poussent des acacias mais qui pousse des
primaires ni des coquelicots lier des
artichauts roumaine ce qui vous
intéresse en lâchant blessés qui pousse
du blé donc l'agriculture historiquement
il faut bien voir que c'est par
construction même une opération de
suppression de la biodiversité donc dire
qu'on va faire de l'agriculture qui
préserve la biodiversité c'est déjà
quelque part un peu un oxymore il ya
quelque chose qui est déjà un peu
intrinsèquement contradictoires en son
sein mais quand même il ya alors c'est
quoi une agriculture qui préserve un peu
mieux la biodiversité
bah c'est une agriculture ou
on remet des prédateurs naturels pour
s'occuper des petites bêtes qui me
manque tine
c'est éventuellement une agriculture
dans laquelle on mélange des espèces
donc en fait on a de la biodiversité
agricole
on a de la biodiversité en termes de
cultivars c'est-à-dire de plantes
compagnes
donc il ya un certain nombre d'éléments
là dedans qui me semblent intéressants
en violence pourrait détailler un peu
mais qui me semble intéressant
après il ya un deuxième élément c'est
que l'agriculture aujourd'hui le fait de
l'avoir très fortement spécialisés
conduit à des chaînes logistiques aval
et amont qui sont extrêmement longues
un monde dans lequel vous faites tout le
maïs dans le sud-ouest pour ensuite
l'envoyer en totalité dans des usines
d'aliments pour animaux qui se trouve en
bretagne pour ensuite alimenter tous les
cochons qui se trouve en bretagne pour
ensuite envoyer tous les jambons se
faire c'est aller chez paou et bien ça
c'est l'agriculture exactement c'est un
c'est une chaîne alimentaire ou accroc
ou agroalimentaires qui n'est pas
résiliente parce que ça demande du
transport à tous les étages et donc sa
demande du pétrole et donc c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas résilient et qui par
ailleurs contribuer indirectement aux
émissions mais surtout ces parisiens
donc le or dans l'agriculture bio il ya
un effort
une attention déclaré on va dire
d'essayer de raccourcir les chaînes
logistiques alors le bio n'est qu'un
label parmi d'autres c'est peut-être pas
le meilleur label qui soit je me sépare
aujourd'hui des labels on commence à en
voir plusieurs par exemple l'agriculture
de conservation des sols pour remettre
du carbone dans le sol est aussi quelque
chose qui à sa pertinence
est ce que c'est bien moins bien que le
bio à côté en plus bon donc le bio c'est
un label qui a des avantages qui a aussi
quelques inconvénients parfois et en
particulier il en a un c'est que dans
les grandes cultures
donc le blé le maïs etc il conduit à
diviser les rendements quasiment un
facteur de ce qui veut dire que si on
veut manger bio à type de régime
alimentaire inchangés c'est-à-dire en
mangeant les mêmes quantités de la même
chose
eh bien vous avez besoin en passant au
bio pour tout ce qui vient des grandes
cultures et notamment les animaux
puisque l'essentiel des grandes que le
tour n'a ici rien nourrir des animaux la
moitié du blé enfin alors les pâturages
c'est pas des grandes cultures en france
et les grandes surfaces
alors là le bio l'occurrence des mines
est pas tellement les rendements mais je
pensais surtout aux céréales et bien ça
veut dire que vous allez avoir besoin de
plus de surface donc en gros si vous
passez en bio à type d'alimentation
inchangé sur tout ce qui dépend des
céréales et bien vous vous retrouvez
paradoxalement avec alors un gain sur la
partie pas de phytosanitaires etc
mais une perte sur la partie occupation
des espaces puisque vous allez avoir
besoin de plus d'espacé au détriment
peut-être de la biodiversité au
détriment à l'évidence des cultures
énergétiques ou d où des espaces occupés
pour avoir du matériau donc un arbitrage
à faire
entre la nuisance j'ai envie à engrais
phytosanitaires et la nuisance
occupation des espaces pour les grandes
cultures
je pense que c'est beaucoup moins vrai
alors je un pour les quelques
discussions que j'ai eues avec mon
maraîcher bio je pense que c'est moins
vrai en ce qui concerne les cultures
maraîchères donc cet inconvénient de
l'occupation d'espacé - et beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins fort mais par
contre c'est sur les grandes cultures
c'est un vrai sujet ce qui veut dire que
si on va jusqu'au bout de la logique et
qu'on dit que sur les grandes cultures
on va en bio donc on accepte des
méthodes plus douces et ont perdu
rendement à ce moment-là contrepartie
évidente c'est qu'il faut accepter de
manger moins bien on est là payer plus
cher totalement évident donc il ya un an
significativement plus cher donc donc la
caisse d'eau pour finir de répondre à
cette question sur qu'est ce que je
pense de l'agriculture bio en fait je
pense encore une fois pour synthétiser
site en tête le faire l'agriculture
n'est qu'une partie de l'ensemble de
l'occupation des sols
il n'y a pas de système parfait ali
milliards d'individus d'individus sur
terre il n'y a plus de système parfait
donc il ya que dès que des arbitrages à
titre personnel mais là je pense qu'on
rentre dans un d'éléments de préférence
personnelle à nouveau parce que encore
une fois dur et versus profiter c'est un
élément préférences personnelles
il n'y a pas de ya pas de vérité divine
est ce que on a raison de cramer la
chandelle par les quatre bouts pour que
la fête soit plus intense dans quel dur
c'est un élément d'arbitrage personnel
il ya des gens qui pensent que non il ya
des gens qui pensent que oui et c'est il
ya pas de vérité scientifique l'être
dans la garrigue moral donc est-ce que
l'agriculture bio au nom d'une vérité
scientifique doit s'imposer non est-ce
que elle doit s'imposer ou directement
est ce que ce genre de pratiques a du
sens si on veut donner plus de poids à
quelque chose de plus doux plus durable
et
j'ai envie de dire plus résilient là la
réponse est plutôt oui
est ce qu'il ya des contreparties
importantes la réponse est oui dont je
viens de parler d'une quantité de viande
dont on peut disposer et bien évidemment
ça veut dire aussi que il va falloir
remplacer une partie des auxiliaires
chimiques par des auxiliaires manuel
donc c'est très cohérent avec le fait de
remettre du monde dans l'agriculture
faut avoir envie d'aller ramasser les
mauvaises herbes
voilà quand on le fait on trouve que ça
fait un peu mal au dos et ça va
nécessairement avec une hausse des prix
des produits agricoles
alors est-ce que c'est nécessairement un
drame non je rappelle quand même quelque
chose qui moi m'a beaucoup frappé quand
j'ai quand j'ai vu le résultat
en 1800 les deux tiers de la population
active en france travailler dans
l'agriculture
si on admet ce qui est une approximation
grossière mais si on admet que les gens
gagnaient à ce moment là la même chose
ou qu'ils travaillent
c'est à dire qu'ils travaillent dans les
services c'est-à-dire comme employée de
maison ou comme vendeur dans l'industrie
c'est à dire à l'époque essentiellement
comme artisan ou dans les champs il
gagnait à peu près la même chose qui
dire à peu près peut-être un peu moins
un peu plus ça revient à dire que la
nourriture à cette époque-là coûtait
entre la moitié et les deux tiers de
leur budget aux ménages donc se nourrir
en 1800 coûtait aux ménages entre la
moitié et les deux tiers de ce qu'ils
gagnaient l'essentiel des gens habités
par ailleurs la campagne donc se loger
ben ils logeaient dans leurs propres
fermes
il n'y avait pas vraiment de distinguo
entre le bâtiment d'exploitation et le
bâtiment d'habitation le aujourd'hui la
nourriture coûte 2 % de ce qu'on gagne
alors vous allez me dire non dans mon
ticket de caisse c'est beaucoup plus que
ça quand je vais au supermarché et temps
en temps je vais au restaurant alors oui
c'est absolument certain que c'est
beaucoup plus que ça mais sauf que dans
un ticket de caisse au supermarché vous
n'avez pas que de la nourriture
vous avez le salaire du magasinier de la
caissière ou de cacher la gazinière peu
importe vous avez la campagne de pub du
magasin vous avez la construction du
magasin vous avez le salaire du
transporteur routier qui a ramené les
denrées jusqu'au magasin vous avez le
salaire
jean d'arkema qui ont fabriqué les
emballages en plastique qui vont
emballer la nourriture
vous avez la facture d'électricité du
magasin bref vous avez les dividendes
des actionnaires vous avez tout sauf de
la nourriture pour 80 % de ce que vous
allez payer donc et quand vous allez au
restaurant c'est bien encore donc le
principe hier encore la nourriture
représente une partie beaucoup plus
faible encore donc en fait le prix de la
nourriture a été considérablement
diminué sur les deux derniers siècles et
même depuis le début du 20e siècle
ça a encore été très très fortement
enfin ça a très fortement baissé et donc
le sens de l'histoire me semble-t-il
c'est que le prix de la nourriture
réaugmente à l'avenir donc en gros dans
notre budget il faudra qu'on fasse une
part plus importante aux prix de la
nourriture et donc il y aura une part
moins importante pour s'acheter des
chaussures des smartphones des meubles
et partir en vacances c'est probablement
ça malheureusement ou heureusement c'est
le sens de l'histoire
donc dans ce schéma là le bio ou pas en
tant que label en dehors duquel il n'y a
pas de vérité mais le bio en tant que
représentant d'une tendance consistant à
dire il va falloir faire avec des
méthodes plus douces et plus durable si
on al'intention de durée cette
répétition me semble représenter quelque
chose de pertinent
voilà après on peut discuter des points
de détail du label on peut dire que il
faut en créer d'autres on peut dire etc
mais ça mais ça indique une tendance
d'adoucir les pratiques agricoles mais
dino flotte
j'insiste que avec deux côtes ici
l'important mieux payer les produits
issus de l'agriculture et par ailleurs
manger moins de viande
voilà c'est ça les deux les deux
éléments
sans lesquels l'équation ensemble aura
beaucoup de mal à flotter alors après
j'ai une question sur la forêt il ya
quelqu'un qui me dit est ce qu'il est
toujours aussi judicieux de planter des
espèces locales ou faut-il commencer à
réfléchir à importer des espèces plus
résistance afin de pouvoir survivre aux
changements climatiques
alors là là pour le coup avoir poser la
question c'est y avoir répondu dans la
mesure où le climat va continuer à
dériver à partir de maintenant pendant
encore des siècles il est évident qu'il
faut en tenir compte
quand on a une espèce qui met des
dizaines d'années voire des siècles à
pousser donc oui bien évidemment il faut
tenir compte aujourd'hui de ce que
seront les conditions de demain alors
parfois ça pose des problèmes
par exemple vous avez des espèces qui
sont bien adaptées à des conditions
arides et chaude et malheureusement elle
supporte pas de gel tant qu'il restera
encore du gel ou moyennes latitudes
c'est compliqué vous avez des espèces
qui supporte bien les conditions arides
et chaude et qui sont à croissance lente
et même quand tout va bien ça reste des
espèces à croissance lente
donc ça veut dire que en gros vous
pouvez pas profiter de l'optimum de la
production de bois donc tout va bien
parce que vous êtes obligés d'entrer de
jeu de planter des trucs qui résiste
beaucoup mieux à des conditions adverses
se pendre à un arbre par exemple qui est
vif leaf résiste assez bien la chaleur
et à la sécheresse mais sauf que même
quand il flotte et qu' il fait doux ben
ali fille beaucoup plus vite
donc si vous voulez avoir du bois d'if
pour faire de la charpente un peu un peu
compliqué voilà donc vous êtes vous avez
des bois de montagne qui résiste assez
bien à la fois à la chaleur et à la le
mélèze par exemple il résiste assez bien
adhérer des conditions voilà mais ça
pousse pas vite
donc vous avez là c'est pareil à un
arbitrage à faire on ne peut pas gagner
sur tous les tableaux
aujourd'hui on a sélectionné des espèces
forestières
exactement comme les espèces agricoles
qui performent bien dans des conditions
climatiques un peu étroite qui sont
celles de leurs zones d'implantation
dans un climat stable mais dans un
climat qui se met à se balader dans des
plages qui varient au cours du temps
c'est pas nécessairement des espèces
adaptées
ça sera plus difficile donc oui il faut
en tenir compte
alors au sein de la gestion forestière
du pays
alors si je parle je suis désolé pour
mon interlocuteur non pas de la belgique
mais de la france mais en fait ça vaut
évidemment pour les ardennes eh bien il
me semble que il est important que dès à
présent on non plus ça dans la gestion
des espèces forestières alors que ça
peut vouloir dire plusieurs choses ça
peut vouloir dire récolter avant l'heure
des espèces qui sinon vous mourir sur
pied c'est à dire on sait qu'on l'ait
récoltera pas à l'optimum en attendant
qu'elle soit vraiment au moment où ça
nous arrangerait le plus
mais sauf que si on attend eh bien on
risque de ne pas les récolter du tout
est d'avoir comme les épicéas et leur
scolytes des arbres morts qu'on peut
plus exploitée donc là on a une première
question à se poser avec une réponse pas
simple parce que je rappelle que
l'expérience qu'on est en train de vivre
est un grand saut dans l'inconnu et le
grand un côté très désagréable de
l'inconnu c'est qu'il est inconnu donc
essayez de la proximité on peut essayer
d'avoir voilà mais on connaîtra pas de
toiles avance donc à ça il ya qu est-ce
qu on replante une fois qu'on a coupé il
ya est ce qu on diversifie pour avoir
des forêts qui sont plus résistantes à
la propagation des maladies par exemple
un article est paru dans une revue
scientifique ya pas longtemps qui
montrait que quand on augmentait le
nombre d'espèces sur une parcelle en
fait la probabilité qu'on chope au moins
une maladie sur une espèce augmentait
mais que par contre la probabilité que
la totalité de la parcelle moeurs bce
paraît pas complètement
pas très étonnant et papa pas difficile
à comprendre
et bien aujourd'hui avec des forts et
gondo spécifiques tant qu'on est à
l'abri de la maladie qui concerne de
l'arbre ou du ravageur qui concerne
l'art pour concerner tout va bien par
contre s'il y en a un qui arrive là tout
va mal et on perd tout enfin on peut
potentiellement tout perdre pour être
plus précis et bien la bonne question
c'est est ce qu'on fait des forêts plus
diversifiés comme la nature et à ce
moment on a globalement une résistance
un peu plus élevée par contre on a une
gestion forestière plus compliqué parce
que ça veut dire que vous devez aller
chercher trois arbres ici trois arbres
là et c est ça coûte plus cher voilà
donc il ya toutes ces questions là se
pose alors j'ai pas la réponse je
n'aurai pas la prétention d'avoir la
réponse à toutes ces questions là dans
ce que je suis en train de dire par
contre ce dont je suis absolument
certain c'est que il est urgent de
mettre du cerveau dans ce genre de
réflexion est aujourd'hui un des drames
qu'il y a alors ça concerne pas que la
gestion forestière j'ai envie de dire ça
concerne l'ensemble des segments de
l'économie mais l'un des drames qu'il y
assez que le coût marginal de faire
réfléchir des gens à ce qu'il serait
pertinent de faire dans un monde qui
deviendrait très chahutées il est
totalement ridicule je veux dire aller à
l'échelle d'un secteur économique à
avoir 50 personnes qui réfléchissent et
qu'ils aient qui se pose la question de
savoir où sont les optimum où sont les
arbitrages dans ce genre d'univers ses
traits voit rien quoi je veux dire plus
en plus des gens qui seraient d'accord
pour commencer à réfléchir à ça on en
trouve on se ramasse
on se blesse on en ramasse à la pelle et
on le fait peu ou pas assez et donc j'ai
envie de dire que la première chose à
faire est là où vraiment la question
pour moi se pose même pas c'est
évidemment c'est un choix personnel
c'est ça serait de commencer par faire
ça de créer ce corpus de connaissances
qui permet de savoir un peu mon mail etc
et alors il ya des expérimentations qui
se font un lot nf a par exemple les
arboretums c'est à dire qu'il ya un
certain nombre de places l'espace moi
j'en ai visité un dans les landes où il
installe tout un tas d'espèces pour voir
comment au fil du temps ces espèces se
porte est-ce que la même espèce plantés
ici les planter là se porte plutôt mieux
ou planter là l'horizon à tout un réseau
d'arboretum qui va de la norvège
jusqu'au portugal
et puis il regarde comment ça se passe
c'est essentiel
c'est utile mais ça ne suffira pas parce
que au moment où on a la réponse quelque
part c'est trop tard donc le mais ça
participe nécessairement d'expériences
utiles et du reste de mémoire cette le
représentant de l'eau nf avec qui
j'avais discuté il m'avait dit qu'il
manquait d'argent et ils manquaient de
surface pour faire ce genre d'expérience
bon ben voila quand j'entends ça je suis
un peu triste parce que je me dis c'est
quand même pas l'argent que ça coûtait
faire à l'échelle des 2200 milliards
d'euros de pib du pays
on en ferait un peu moins dans la 5g et
un peu plus dans ce genre de trucs
je pense que la collectivité y
gagneraient donc c'est pas tellement
l'argent qui manque pour faire ce genre
de choses c'est vraiment la volonté de
fer et des arbitrages
voilà donc pour finir cette longue
réponse sur la forêt on ne sait pas tout
s'est compliqué en plus le vivant c'est
compliqué c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'il est donc moi je fais quelque part
un métier facile face aux biologistes
mais même si c'est compliqué même si
c'est un certain ben faut y aller donc
il faut mettre beaucoup plus donc il
faut être capable de répondre à la
question qui m'a été posée où commençait
à avoir des éléments qui sont un peu
plus sophistiqué que juste dire oui ça
serait pas idiot d'y penser
voilà enfin ce stade ce que je peux vous
dire c'est oui ça serait pas idiot d'y
penser mais il est évident que il faut
très vite ou le plus vite possible
avoir des éléments beaucoup plus
circonstanciée à vous proposer en
réponse à cette à cette question alors
après il y avait une question qui va
rebondir sur ce que j'ai raconté tout à
l'heure sur l'agriculture qui est
comment la france va-t-elle gérer ces
forêts optimisation entre le stockage de
carbone protection de la biodiversité
utilisation du bois pour chauffer la
construction etc
alors c'est un sous-ensemble de ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur l'occupation
des sols
c'est à dire les sols c'est agriculture
énergie matériaux en france les deux
universités eh bien là c'est pareil à
l'intérieur du segment forestier donc là
je viens de donner un élément de réponse
en disant est ce qu'il faut diversifier
les forêts pour les rendre plus
résiliente
à ce moment ci vous diversifier les
forêts pour les rendre plus résiliente
eh bien vous ne pouvez pas les dédier un
seul usage vous aurez à la fois là
dedans du taillis du bois pour l'énergie
du bois pour la construction du bois qui
sert à rien entre lee mais enfin qu'il
sera juste là pour la biodiversité
donc c
je n'ai pas non plus la réponse à cette
question de manière formelle je suis pas
forestier ggg des avis sur les questions
qui conviennent se poser donc s'ils sont
essentiellement celles que j'ai évoqué
juste avant et j'ai un avis sur la
manière de rentrer en sujet c'est-à-dire
de payer des gens pour y réfléchir et à
ce stade j'ai malheureusement pas et
j'ai quelques petits éléments de
conviction qui est que de faire d'effort
est aujourd'hui totalement mono
spécifique dans le contexte climatique
qui nous attend ce n'est pas une bonne
idée
à part ça bach ma foi je le relis il
faut il faut regarder difficile pour moi
de venir des choses beaucoup plus
[Musique]
beaucoup plus précise que ça alors c'est
que c'est pas suffisant pour sauver
l'humanité de reboiser la terre et de
planter des arbres alors ce qu'on
appelle oui ça c'est ça c'est clair
et donc est ce qu'il faudra recourir à
des technologies d'aspiration du co2
dans l'air a alors oui ça n'est pas
suffisant aujourd'hui de planter des
arbres pour compenser nos émissions de
co2 c'est très clair aujourd'hui les
écosystèmes naturels absorbent en gros
un quart des émissions humaines donc
vous pourriez vous dire au premier ordre
il faudra les x 4 sauf qu'aujourd'hui
les forêts couvrent un quart des terres
émergées donc si on les multiplie par
quatre il n'y a plus du tout l'espace
pour se nourrir donc on voit bien que
on a un petit sujet donc oui ça suffit
maintenant ça suffit d'autant moins que
pour le moment malheureusement c'est
plutôt l'inversé qui se passe c'est à
dire que l'expansion démographique
continue à conduire à supprimer des
forêts pour y mettre des cultures est
par ailleurs qu'une partie des
écosystèmes naturels et une partie des
forêts sont déjà en train de souffrir de
s'affaiblir voire risqué de dépérir
alors lentement ses chevalets s'est
brutalement par incendie ce qui s'est
passé en australie il ya un an là on a
quand même un tiers de la superficie
française en gros qui a brûlé donc on a
à peu près 20 millions d'hectares qui
ont brûlé la superficie française c'est
donc on n'est pas en train de parler de
cacahuètes et bien évidemment c'est des
écosystèmes qui vont mettre très
longtemps à se reconstituer et peut-être
que pour une partie que je ne connais
pas cette reconstitution n'arrivera pas
il ya un risque majeur d'assèchement du
bassin amazonien donc avant même les
turpitudes de notre ami paul sun araw il
ya enfin pas tout seul dans cette
histoire parce que la déforestation
amazonienne on en importe une partie à
chaque fois qu'on achète du soja ou un
coup ne sais pas ce n'est pas juste pas
le seul à rouen cette histoire est bien
s'il ya un assèchement significatif du
bassin amazonien on aura beau il
plantait des arbres et ici à face il
poussera des arbustes
il poussera plus des arbres donc enfin
oui on va s'en va se récupérer un
écosystème plus secs stocks en moins de
carbone et voilà donc le planter des
arbres oui c'est utile de le faire à
chaque fois qu'on peut
c'est utile de ne pas les enlever
surtout à chaque fois qu'on met pour
autant ça ne peut pas être la seule voie
de réponse à la problèmes climatiques il
est absolument impératif de baisser les
émissions qui finiront par d'essayer de
toute façon un jour parce que la planète
est fini mais il serait sage de le faire
de nous mêmes et d'une façon organisée
après est-ce qu'on peut suppléer à sa
part des moyens technologiques alors là
la réponse est malheureusement non le
co2 le dioxyde de carbone est une
molécule inertes comme tous les oxydes
qui sont des molécules inerte c'est à
dire que les oxydants général ne
réagissent pas de manière spontanée avec
d'autres molécules pour faire autre
chose que des oxydes il faut apporter de
l'énergie un oxyde pour qu'il veuille
bien cesser d'être un oxyde donc c'est
ce qui se passe avec la photosynthèse la
photosynthèse c'est une réduction du
dioxyde de carbone
on enlève l'oxygène au carbone et le
fait d'enlever l'oxygène se fait pas ce
qu'il ya de l'énergie d'un photon
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça la
photosynthèse dans le qui arrive sur la
plante qui opère cette réaction comme le
co2 est une molécule inerte et que par
ailleurs il est très dilué dans
l'atmosphère le co2 il est diluée à 0
via le 0 4% dans l'atmosphère aller
récupérer une molécule inerte diluée à 0
04 % dans l'atmosphère demande beaucoup
d'énergie
ça demande beaucoup d'énergie c'est là
sa vedette qui veut pas du tout se
laisser attraper et ya pas beaucoup de
savonnettes donc il faut beaucoup par
pente et l'atmosphère y avoir des bras
très musclé pour que pour retenir la
savonnette
sinon ça marche pas alors en pratique ce
qu'on appelle direct air capture est un
processus par lequel on fait passer
l'air atmosphérique sur d un absorbant
du co2 alors dans les centrales à
charbon c'est les amines là j'ai pas
regardé sur mettaya capture si c'est le
même le même composant est derrière mais
je pense que oui parce que derrière on
ce que j'ai lu indiqué qu'il fallait
chauffer la substance qui avait absorbé
le co2 et en l'occurrence les abîmes
c'est comme ça qu'on descende de co2
c'est en chauffant donc en gros fait
passer l'air sur un sur un fluide qui va
à gripper on va dire le co2 contenu dans
l'air en fait y'a pas beaucoup de co2
dans l'air donc il faut un énorme
brassage mécanique avec beaucoup
d'énergie pour faire passer beaucoup
d'air et puis ensuite une fois que le
co2 est agrippé dans ce fluide qui dès
qu'il a été retenu dans ce fluide il
faut chauffer de fluides pour que le
foot c'est par bel et bien divorcer du
co2 et ce chauffage demande de l'énergie
et un petit calcul de coin de table que
je vous livre non vérifiés mais enfin
voila j'ai faits semblent indiquer que
pour reprendre à l'atmosphère le co2 que
nous y mettons annuellement avec ce
genre de processus
il faudrait disposer de plusieurs fois
l'énergie aujourd'hui consommée par
l'humanité d'accord il faudra dix points
rien que pour alimenter ce processus là
et il faudra mettre l'équivalent
d'arbres c'est à dire des objets
technologiques fait de métal à peu près
en même quantité sur terre donc un quart
des terres émergées devra être couvert
de genre de truc je vous laisse imaginer
le tableau donc la vraisemblance qu'on
arrive à faire ça à un horizon de temps
raisonnable c'est-à-dire d'ici à ce que
mes enfants et mon âge me paraît pas
complètement assurée on va dire voilà
donc vous oubliez ce genre de truc si je
suis très cash dans ma réponse
ça ne sera absolument pas un déterminant
significatif de la lutte contre le
changement climatique
par contre
diminuer la quantité de viande qu'on
mange et essayer du moins mal possible
d'arrêter la croissance démographique
pour éviter de déforester ça sent
beaucoup plus utile que de commencer à
faire joujou avec ce genre de
technologie ce qui peut avoir un de
l'impact c'est d'empêcher le co2 partir
dans l'air alors là on parle pas du
direct air capture donc d'aller chercher
le co2 une fois qu'il est dans l'air on
parle de l'empêcher d'y aller et là on
passe de la capture et séquestration
donc là on met espèce de grosse
panthères sa co2 mais c'est la même
chose c'est un bande am inn ont fait
passer le co2 d'une fumée sur un banc
des mines puis on chauffe les à mina
pour récupérer le co2 alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on fait passer la fumée dans
la fumée ya autre chose dans la
combustion dans une combustion à l'air
vous avez plein de votes qu'il faut
séparer du co2 c'est pour ça qu'on fait
passer ça sur un lit damine vous avez
d'autres processus dans lesquels on peut
avoir du co2 pure mais à ce moment le
processus est à la bombe
c'est avec de l'oxycombustion de la
gazéification et à ce moment le
processus est un peu compliquée et
tellement peu importe une fois que vous
allez hop co2 vous pouvez l'enfouir sous
terre alors c'est des choses qu'on sait
faire
les norvégiens savent très bien faire ça
parce que dans les gisements de gaz
naturel de la mer du nord vous avez du
co2 en quantités significatives entre 5
et 10% et ce co2 vous pouvez évidemment
pas le mettre dans les tuyaux gaz le gaz
de votre cuisinière il contient pas du
tout de co2 c'est même interdit et donc
ce co2 qui est séparé en tête depuis il
faut bien en faire quelque chose alors
qu'historiquement les norvégiens le
laisser partir dans l'air mais l'état
norvégien qui ne se remet toujours pas
d'avoir fait fortune dans le pétrole a
dit non non vous pouvez pas faire ça
c'est pas bien donc
remettez le donc enfin fait dans autre
chose et donc les norvégiens ont dit pas
très bien on va le remettre sous terre
puisqu'on a fait sortir du pétrole et du
gaz il ya de la place sous terre donc on
va mettre le co2 à la place donc c'est
exactement ça qu'ils font mais il n'y a
pas de combustion dans cette affaire
c'est directement une séparation entre
du méthane et du co2 donc c'est plus
simple comme procédé on pourrait faire
ça avec la production d'hydrogène
quand on produit de l'hydrogène par
réformage de méthane
donc on mélange de la vapeur d'eau et du
méthane ch4 on je trouve ça très fort et
ça fait de l'hydrogène et du co2 le co2
qu on obtient une cure
donc là on peut le prendre et le
séquestrer voilà senti un truc qu'on
pourrait faire mais ça demande quand
même une dépense énergétique qui est pas
nul
ça demande un endroit où mettre le co2
sa demande de bâtir des tuyaux de co2
etc
donc ça ça peut représenter une marge de
manoeuvre déjà plus importante que le
d'ailleurs été clair capture qui sera
donc on va dire ça veut faire quelques
articles qui amuseront la galerie dans
quelques journaux mais ça sera jamais
quelque chose de très significatif
par contre la ccs peut représenter plus
de zéro on va dire est ce que ça sera
significatif dans le paysage
personnellement j'ai du mal à le croire
parce que quand on fait des calculs
d'ordre de grandeur là aussi on se rend
compte que si ça permet de séquestrer
allez on va dire 5% des émissions
humaines se fera le bout du monde
d'ici là d'ici à 2030 ou d'ici à 2050
pardon mais bon 5 % si on y arrive c'est
toujours bon à prendre
voilà mais c'est mais c'est quelque
chose qui demande par contre des gros
investissements capitalistiques et qui
se passe pas en un claquement de doigts
alors après à il ya un sujet qui est
celui des herbivores
est ce qu'il faut faire la guerre aux
herbivores
alors qu'on a besoin des herbivores là
où il ya des pâturages parce qu'on vient
en fait rien d'autre et que par ailleurs
sa ca amendes les sols avec le cas car
alors c'est pas exactement comme ça que
la question est posée mais donc faut-il
pas réorienter les systèmes de
production de viande et de lait plutôt
que de chercher à l'eba dira alors ma
réponse est oui il ya un article qui a
été publié il ya quelques îles ya deux
ans et qui avait été présenté aux
ateliers du shift donc si vous retrouvez
les vidéos des ateliers du chiffre il ya
deux trois ans d'un chercheur qui
s'appelle pedros chatting pyros et qui
avait montré que dans un contexte de
diminution forte des cheptels
en fait c'était il fallait conserver des
ruminants et supprimés essentiellement
les monogastriques donc en gros les
cochons et les poulets alors baissé
beaucoup le nombre de ruminants d'abord
parce que ça fait du méthane et ensuite
parce que ça demande des cultures à la
main qu'ils sont
qui sont elles mêmes productrice de gaz
à effet de serre parce qu'à des engrais
et occupe et qui demande de l'espace
donc si je résume en gros on a beaucoup
moins de poulet beaucoup moins de cochon
et on garde des vaches essentiellement
là où il ya des pâturages et où on peut
rien faire d'autre
je schématise mais c'est à peu près ça
le sait à peu près ça l'idée alors je ne
je n'ai pas regardé pour être très franc
si ce point de vue
quidam qui qui qui rencontrent afin
qu'il ya un certain nombre de partisans
dans le monde agronomique et est
totalement compatible avec l'éradication
et à quel horizon avec l'éradication des
émissions humaines de gaz à effet de
serre ou avec leur compensation par des
puits mais en tout cas c'est un point de
vue intéressant je trouve
parce que effectivement c'est compliqué
de mettre des poulets ou des cochons
dans des prés compliqué de le faire
manger que ça enfin si les poules voulez
vous pouvez les mettre dans des prés et
mes productions que des bovins et donc
le bovin est une bonne manière de
valoriser les surfaces où il n'avait que
des pâturages la montagne les espaces un
peu un peu pauvre etc
et puis ailleurs dans le monde alors
j'ai envie de dire là pour le moment je
suis prudent mais le l'hypothèse que
j'ai envie de tester en tout cas c'est
vers ça qu'on s'achemine dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
donc là on est à un horizon de temps qui
est pas encore plus l'infini mais qui
est les années décennies à venir
c'est qu'il ya au moins une première
étape qui semble pertinente dans cette
affaire qui est de diviser le cheptel
bovin par deux de laisser
essentiellement les bovins à l'herbe
c'est à dire qu'en fait les bovins qu'on
conserve ses les bovins à l'herbe ce
conte ce qu'on se qu'on ne conserve pas
dans cette affaire c'est ceux qui sont
au sol stabulation et d'avoir
pour ces bovins à l'herbe un système qui
est un système essentiellement cours
puisqu'ils vont manger essentiellement
de l'herbe et pour les compléments
alimentaires de faire en sorte que ça
vienne pas très loin donc éventuellement
un peu de soja cultivées sur
l'exploitation un peu de luzerne un peu
la luzerne on peut enfin dans beaucoup
de régions
voilà c'est autour de cette idée qu'on
tourne alors cette idée
ça permet de diviser par deux les
émissions de méthane du cheptel et ça
permet de supprimer l'essentiel des
émissions agricoles
ah bon lié à la culture céréalière qui
permet de nourrir les bêtes qui sont
hors sol
alors cette affaire l'a pas
nécessairement avec du côté des éleveurs
une augmentation très forte des prix au
kilo parce que à nouveau il n'y a pas de
raison que ce soit eux les dindons de la
farce dans la mesure où jusqu'à
maintenant ils n'ont fait que répondre à
une demande sociétale qui était donnée
nous faisons de plus paul le plus
possible pour le moins cher possible
donc la filière a répondu à ça et puis
par ailleurs vous pouvez pas demander à
une filière d'innover si elle est pauvre
donc si on veut que l'agriculture y
nomme il faut lui donner de l'argent
l'exigence va avec les moyens sinon ça
marche pas c'est comme dans une
entreprise
si vous êtes exigeants envers des gens
qui vous donnez 0 moyens marche moyen
par d'emploi répétition donc le donc
dans l'agriculture voilà voilà le lead
et autour de laquelle on tourne
qui est d'avoir une réduction
significative des bovins mais en
privilégiant le pâturage qui
effectivement est un système qu'il ya
une logique intéressante et qui est
beaucoup plus ancien que la logique de
l'élevage hors sol qui demande des
chaînes logistiques à montgerval qui
sont beaucoup plus importantes voilà et
donc le je le redis la contrepartie
c'est qu'il faut y compris par des
mécanismes fiscaux ou réglementaires
augmenter la quantité d'argent qui
rentre dans le système par kilo à partir
du moment où c'est comme ça qu'on
s'organise alors après il y avait une
question sur les puits de carbone en
changeant de modèle pour l agriculture
bio ou l'agro écologie ou
l'agroforesterie
donc en fait oui c'est une reformulation
de choses
un tout petit peu vu donc oui c'est il
faut il faut mais il faut la payer pour
sarah j'insiste il faut il faut qu'on
accepte collectivement que si
l'agriculture s'occupe de récupérer une
partie de nos émissions en créant des
puits de carbone alors que c'est pas
nécessairement indispensable pour faire
son fonctionnement direct que si elle
s'occupe de restaurer de la biodiversité
alors que encore une fois à très court
terme
et j'insiste c'est pas indispensable
pour son fonctionnement actuel à ce
moment la collectivité doit accepter la
contrepartie qui va avec c'est à dire de
donner plus d'argent aux agriculteurs ça
me paraît totalement évident que c'est
comme ça que ça doit ça doit fonctionner
donc oui je pense à titre personnel une
fois c'est une opinion qui n'engage que
moi je pense à titre personnel que c'est
une bonne idée d'avoir une agriculture
qui soit plus respectueuse de
l'environnement plus diversifiée
moins dépendante de chaîne logistique
longue plus respectueuse des sols et
moins émettrices de gaz à effet de serre
et tout ça va avec le fait que les gens
il ya plus d'argent alors après passons
au climat a alors il est question sur
l'inertie du système climatique
quelle est la réalité de l'inertie du
système climatique est ce que si on
arrête les émissions demain matin la
température continue de monter ou pas
alors la réponse est un peu mais pas
beaucoup
en fait si on arrête les émissions
demain matin la température se stabilise
assez vite
par contre elle ne décroît quasiment pas
derrière pourquoi est ce que je dis que
les 1,5 degré ils sont déjà embarqué
alors je confesse effectivement quand je
dis ça faire deux choses qui sont pas
exactement 1 située sur le même plan la
première c'est que j'utilise une
simulation du giec qui date de 2014
alors que je pense que valérie utilise
une simulation réalisée qui va figurer
valérie masson-delmotte pas ce que c'est
on me dit qu elle qui est plus récente
et où la bonne nouvelle entre guillemets
c'est que le l'élévation de température
en fonction du budget carbone augmente
un peu moins vite
donc en fait là où avec les graphiques
j'utilisais - qui date du rapport 2014
du giec si ma mémoire est bonne
l'élévation de température pour le
carbone qu'on avait déjà vue dans
l'atmosphère
on avait signé pour 1,5 en fait les
données plus récentes
c'est plutôt qu'on a signé pour 1.2.3
voilà donc le qui en fait l'élévation
quasiment qu'on a qu'on a aujourd'hui
voilà donc les héros de différence
s'explique par le fait que
d'après ce que j'ai compris on ne
travaille pas exactement avec le des
données qui sont datés de la même époque
alors après il ya eu une deuxième
manière d'interpréter la chose qui est
de dire les émissions vont de toute
façon pas baissé vont pas se mettre à
zéro demain matin donc est ce qu'il ya
un réchauffement pas évitable
même avec une baisse drastique des
émissions là ma réponse est oui puisque
le réchauffement de deux degrés demande
à ce que les émissions deviennent quasi
nulle d'ici à 2050
et donc ça ça va avec une baisse des
émissions qui est de l'ordre de 5% par
an à partir de maintenant
alors il ya des gens qui disent que 1,5
degrés pourrait obtenir avec une baisse
de 7% des émissions en fait il faut bien
voir que 7,5 degrés quand vous regardez
scénario c'est en 2100 et c'est pas sur
toute la durée du 21e siècle en fait ce
scénario là vous fait dépassé les 25
degrés dans le coin du 21e siècle
mais ça descend après dans la deuxième
partie du 21e siècle
parce que vous vous mettez à avoir une
absorption nette de co2 en provenance de
l'atmosphère donc en fait ça renvoie à
la question précédemment traité qui est
que dans la deuxième partie du 21e
siècle non seulement les hommes
n'émettent plus rien n'est quasiment
plus rien mais en plus ils ont réussi à
créer des puits tels que le flux net de
carbone chaque année est une
soustraction à l'atmosphère et non pas
une addition à l'atmosphère alors avec
10 milliards de bons à elle sur terre ou
huit
je vous laisse juger de la pertinence de
ce scénario qui consiste à penser qu'on
va re forrest est partout et par
ailleurs avoir un fonctionnement de la
société dans lequel on garde quelque
chose qui n'est pas très éloigné du
fonctionnement actuel avec zéro gramme
de pétrole zéro gramme de charbon et
zéro gramme de gaz
voilà ces scénarios là alors là pour le
coup ils sont passés par valérie
masson-delmotte ils sont faits par des
économistes et ses scénarios là à titre
personnel je n'y crois pas
donc là c'est à titre personnel j'assume
je considère qu'ils n'ont pas de valeur
parce que ils sont faits à partir
d'hypothèses qui sont totalement
contradictoires les unes avec les autres
donc le lien regarde le 5° du scénario
le moins émissifs en fait c'est pas 1,5
degré jamais dépassé au cours du siècle
c'est dépassé et ensuite savez c'est un
peu parce que on arrive à aspirer du co2
en provenance de l'atmosphère
si on est sur un scénario dans lequel à
aucun moment on est capable d'aspirer en
est donc ce qu'on fait au mieux c'est
d'aller vers zéro d'y rester à ce moment
où on dépassera les 1,5
de façon absolument certaine il de façon
extrêmement probable on dépassera les 2
est temps que dans même le scénario à 7%
de baisse des émissions par an à partir
de maintenant
n'en parlons pas même le scénario de 7%
de baisse des émissions à partir de
maintenant
là pour le coup il conduit sur les 20
prochaines années un échauffement qui
est à peu près le même qu'un scénario de
hausse des émissions de 3% par an à
partir de maintenant
sur les 20 prochaines années ces deux
scénarios l'un d'eux se différencie pas
donc sur la partie les 1,5 degré c'est
déjà foutu
en fait j'ai formellement tort au regard
des dernières publications pas de ce qui
va sortir dans le prochain rapport du
giec
parce que la sensibilité du climat a été
un tout petit peu revu à la baisse par
rapport à ce qu'il y avait dans les
simulations précédente
par contre sur le côté quoi qu'on fasse
dans les 20 prochaines années entre le
scénario le plus émissifs est le
scénario le moins émissifs ça ne change
rien sur la trajectoire climatique
là entre l'image et raison au sens où
c'est ce qui sort de graphique
directement issue de publications
scientifiques qui seront donc prises en
compte et que je n'ai pas vu invalidé
jusqu'à maintenant
à cause de l'inertie du système voilà si
je
si je si je schématise avant que si
j'essaye de discriminer voilà le genre
insiste sur le fait que les 1,5 degré en
question encore une fois résulte dans le
graphique que j'utilise actuellement
deci delà des seuls simulation qui
étaient publiées jusqu'à maintenant est
ce que ça fait une grosse différence
cette histoire là que de toute façon ce
soit foutu 1,3 ou 1,5 à mon avis non
parce que ce qui compte vraiment et en
fait c'est là dessus que j'insiste
maintenant dans les exposés c'est
l'inertie des 20 ou 30 prochaines années
quel que soit le scénario des missions
entre je commence à baisser fortement et
je laisse que je continue à laisser les
éditions filet ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut laisser les émissions filet bien au
contraire
parce que au delà de 20 ans ça commence
à devenir très discriminant sur ce qui
va se passer et bon nombre de gens qui
écoutent seront encore vivant dans 20
ans en tout cas je leur souhaite donc le
c'est pas du tout une raison pour être
laxiste mais par contre ça veut dire que
de toute façon sur les 20 prochaines
années il va falloir se couvrir contre
et bien après contre des évolutions qui
vont aller en quantité croissante
après il ya un certain nombre
d'évolutions qui sont mises en route
dans le système climatique même si on
arrivait à contenir l'élévation de
température 1,5 degré elles vont
continuer par exemple la hausse du
niveau des mers
de toute façon ça va continuer par
exemple et des perturbations sur le
cycle hydrologique qui une fois qu'elles
sont là sont permanentes j'ai envie de
dire tant que l'élévation de température
a lieu donc ça veut pas dire parce que
la température s'arrêterait de monter
que les conséquences de cette élévation
de température vont s'arrêter de ceux de
croître il ya un certain nombre de
conséquences qui vont avec qui vont
continuer à croître bien après que la
température soit stabilisé alors c'est
pas une raison
ne pas être précis dans les chiffres
qu'on utilise
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça par
contre
il faut pas le taux auquel il faut faire
attention encore une fois c'est que la
stabilisation de la température
c'est pas la stabilit c'est par la
stabilisation des ennuis c'est
malheureusement les ennuis vont
continuer à augmenter
bien après que la température se
stabilise alors après il ya une question
sur la voiture électrique
pourquoi dépenser des milliards en
recherche et l'investissement pour la
voiture électrique alors qu'elle ne
compte que pour 5% des émissions de co2
mondiales
alors c'est pas la voiture électrique
ainsi la voiture tout coup et que le sec
le modèle n'est pas viable surtout à
cause des batteries ne serait-il pas
plus pertinent de diriger ces fonds vers
la transition énergétique des
cimenteries centrales électriques à
charbon et transport maritime qui sont
les plus gros émetteurs de carbone alors
eu et qui pourrait en disant diminué
d'environ 40% des émissions mondiales
alors malheureusement non en disant on
diminuera pas facilement 40 % des
émissions mondiales
40% des émissions mondiales c'est la
totalité des émissions des centrales à
charbon plus la totalité des émissions
directes de l'industrie donc ça
malheureusement on supprimera pas en
disant c'est pas possible
même si on s'y met d'arrache-pied même
dans les délires les plus fous que le
grand nucléariste que vers les quais mph
à noter que j'étais où on ferait une
accélération massive sur le nucléaire on
n'éradiquera pas le charbon mondiale en
dix ans j'avais de la vie et même dans
les délires les plus fous ou le
nucléaire il va encore plus vite pour
électrifier tous les processus
industriels
on supprimera pas les émissions directes
de l'industrie en disant même dans mes
rêves les plus fous
donc voilà est ce que pour autant ça
veut dire qu'il faut tout miser ou rien
miser sur la voiture électrique alors je
vais essayer d'être un peu précis le
plan de transformation de l'économie
française que va faire
quel en train de faire machine project
est un plan qui se veut systémique donc
en gros notre discours n'est pas de dire
ya un sujet qui est plus important qu'un
autre
lille est de dire il va falloir agir sur
tous les fronts parce que si on vise la
neutralité carbone font plus d'émissions
mule pas donc toutes les émissions sont
a entre guillemets supprimés par contre
l'ordre dans lequel on fait les choses
et a gradué en fonction du plus facile
vers le plus difficile exactement comme
le sudoku
si vous commencez ou comment la piste
même si vous n'avez jamais fait
d'alpinisme et vous commencez
directement par la face nord des grandes
jorasses et bien la probabilité que vous
arriviez vivent en haut on n'est pas
très élevé alors que si vous faites ça
en prédisant entraînement vous avez un
peu plus de chance de le faire
voilà c'est exactement pareil il faut
commencer par les marches les plus
faciles et aller progressivement vers le
plus difficile donc en gros alors les
économistes ont coutume de dire bah
c'est parfait mais dont une taxe sur le
carbone et puis le monde économique ira
d'entrée duo plus facile parce que c'est
là qui réduira pour le moins cher par
tonne de carbone alors c'est un
raisonnement qui a plein de l'élite
je sais pas si j'en parle aujourd'hui ou
si je renvoie ça une autre question qui
ne manquera pas de m'être posé un
prochain facebook live sur les heures et
les malheurs de la taxe carbone mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas aussi
simple que ça par contre ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya une forme de bon sens là
dedans c'est à dire que quelle que soit
la voie d'action qui est privilégiée que
ce soit la voie réglementaire ou la voix
parler signal chimio pris part dont
l'idée de commencer par là que ça va
plus vite n'est pas idiote et
incidemment c'est bien pour ça que à
titre personnel je suis opposé à un
certain nombre de choses de choses qu'on
prétend faire au nom du climat en france
parce qu'en fait on se rend compte que
ça c'est beaucoup d'argent pour des
émissions donc beaucoup de moyens
physiques pour des émissions supprimées
qui sont marginales au nul alors que la
même quantité d'argent c'est à dire les
mêmes moyens physiques employés ailleurs
permettrait d'aller beaucoup plus vite
donc évite par ailleurs la voiture
aujourd'hui est dépendante du pétrole et
même si on se fiche du climat le pétrole
est une ressource épuisable
il faut savoir que les transports sont
aujourd'hui dépendant à 98% dans 95
maintenant du pétrole et bleu pétrole il
y en aura pas pour l'éternité donc se
déplacer autrement qu'avec du pétrole et
de toute façon un sujet qui reste qui
restent pertinents donc oui il faut
s'occuper de faire autre chose que des
voitures à essence
alors maintenant est ce qu'il faut faire
des voitures électriques pas
nécessairement on peut faire des
véhicules électriques
donc on peut faire des vélos électriques
on peut faire des trains électriques
on peut faire des voix là on peut faire
plein d'autres véhicules électriques que
simplement de la voiture électrique et
ce qui est absolument certain c'est que
la pire des choses à faire c'est de
commencer par faire des tanks électrique
donc des voitures de deux tonnes à titre
personnel je serais pour l'interdiction
ce genre de truc donc pour obliger les
constructeurs à faire de moins en moins
de pétrole ont leur interdisant de
dépasser une certaine masse pour les
véhicules électriques qui construisent
je pense que la réglementation
européenne qui ferait ça sera une
réglementation utile parce que là on est
juste en train de faire des véhicules
pour bros qui cherche à donner votre
conscience
si je suis un peu désagréable donc le
donc le faire des véhicules électriques
oui mais je le redis on peut faire des
vélos électriques un vélo électrique
c'est 100 fois moins de capacité de
batterie qu'une voiture s'est alors je
me rappelle plus des ratios exact mais
enfin c'est entre 10 et 20 fois moins
d'occupation d'espacé au sol
c'est en gros
cent fois moins de matériaux mobilisés
alors plutôt 50 un vélo électrique ça
pèse 20 kilos une voiture ça pèse une
tonne donc hélas on peut très bien
dépensé des milliards ont recherché en
investissement parce que des milliards à
l'échelle de l'économie mondiale ou même
française s'est pas beaucoup je rappelle
que le pib français ses 2200 milliards
d'euros le pib européen doit se balader
ou faire un tour de 12000 donc si pour
un pib européen qui fait douze mille
milliards d'euros par an on dépense 5
milliards d'euros par an en r&d sur le
véhicule électrique bien problème avec
ça la question si elle ce qu'on doit
déployer des véhicules électriques d'une
tonne pour remplacer le milliard de
voitures qui circulent actuellement dans
le monde
et là la réponse est non il faut s'y
prendre autrement alors je vous renvoie
aux travaux du chiffre project qui ont
porté sur la mobilité dans les zones de
moyenne densité en fait essentiellement
la mobilité du quotidien et je vous
renvoie par avance à ce qui va sortir
dans le cadre du chief projet fin du
plan de transformation l'économie
française où on aura différencier
mobilité longue distance et mobilité du
quotidien parce que les motifs de
déplacement sont pas du tout les mêmes
la longue distance c'est pour se balader
c'est essentiellement loisirs le
quotidien c'est essentiellement pour des
trajets dit obligé à l'epo c'est aller à
l'école enfin l'écossé
sauf que les travaux allaient à l'école
aller faire ses courses
enfin bref c'est des choses qu'on fait
j'ai envie de dire avec une marge de
manoeuvre qui est moins importante que
pour aller voir sa belle mère ou les
changer les idées et donc le
donc dépenser des milliards encore une
fois pour que tout ça change post 1 tu
enlèves le dans les marges de manoeuvre
que l'on propose o'shea project donc sur
la mobilité du quotidien il ya un
cocktail dans lequel n'y a pas que la
voiture électrique qui a le covoiturage
à l'électrification il ya le vélo
électrique ou pas électrique
il ya les transports en commun et à la
marche donc offert un cocktail de tout
ça et puis à plus long terme il ya un
sujet urbanisme il est bien évident que
quand on a pâti d'urbanisme autour de la
voiture c'est plus difficile de se
passer de la voiture
donc j'ai envie de dire qu'à l'horizon
de 50 ou 100 ans la quantité de voitures
électriques dont on aura besoin dépend
aussi de l'urbanisme et enfin dernier
point
s'il ya un segment de transport a
électrifié en priorité encore plus que
tout chien de tout ce que je viens
d'évoquer pardon je pencherais plutôt
pour le fret
parce que les marchandises non pas de
jambes et donc les gens eux et pas
utiliser leurs jambes donc on n'a plus
de voiture on remonte sur un vélo alors
on râle c'est un peu plus ses longues
etc
mais bon si nécessité fait loi on y
arrivera alors que mettez un colis sur
un vélo aux pédales wah pas tout seul
donc vous avez aussi un sujet
d'électrification des utilitaires et la
l'utilitaire il transporte donc c'est
alors on peut faire des utilitaires e vo
cargo et c'est donc toute cette
réflexion et dans est en cours
et oui d'électrification est le seul
moyen de conserver les transports à
assistance mécanique dans un monde dans
lequel le pétrole aura disparu parce que
par ailleurs je suis de plus en plus
perplexes en ce qui me concerne sur ce
qu'on appelle les biocarburants et qui
sont en fait des agrocarburants parce
que dans les usages des terres que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure si je fais une
hiérarchie dans les usages des ter entre
biodiversité se nourrir matériaux c'est
à dire bois il fibres et infrastructures
le truc que j'ai envie de mettre tout en
bas tout en bas c'est les agrocarburants
c'est vraiment le truc qu'on fait si
noir de l'espace
aujourd'hui nous en fait pas il nous en
reste pas donc plutôt que d'avoir des
voitures qui consomment toujours la même
chose dans lesquelles il ya 10 ou 20%
d'agrocarburants qui rentre avec le
pétrole eh bien je préfère de très loin
que les voitures consomment la moitié de
ce qu'a conserve aujourd'hui et qu'on
impose sa réglementairement et que l'on
n'ait pas besoin des surfaces pour faire
des agrocarburants et si on a besoin de
payer des agriculteurs
truc intelligent et bien il ya plein de
trucs intelligents à leur faire faire
dans lesquels je crois avoir évoqué
quelques possibilités lors d'une
question précédente donc à titre
personnel les agrocarburants je pense
que il faut arrêter et il faut viser 2
sans passer par la sobriété et
d'électrification et la sobriété est
évidemment la première marche de
manoeuvre je le redis quand on remplace
une voiture par un vélo diviser la masse
de matière à transportées indépendamment
de la carcasse par un facteur 50 c'est
pas un petit gars c'est quelque chose
d'absolument massif
voilà on attend donc j'avais une
deuxième partie à la question qui est ce
qu'ils font pas diriger ces fonds vers
la transition énergétique des
cimenteries mais il faut aussi faire la
transition énergétique des cimenteries
il faut pas voilà c'est pas où c'était
et des centrales à charbon bien sûr
alors même motif même punition
en ce qui concerne la cimenterie et en
ce qui concerne les centrales à charbon
et bien il faudra mélanger sobriété et
décarbonation c'est toujours l'équation
de kaya quelque part qu'on applique à
tous ces secteurs
c'est exactement comme ça qu'on est en
train de résonner dans plan de
transformation si avec des équations de
kaya appliquée à tous les secteurs alors
dans le domaine français de la
cimenterie
je peux déjà vous dire que on ne fera
pas l'impasse sur les volumes produits
on se prononcera sur le fait que les
volumes produits doivent baisser après
par tonne produite il faudra aussi faire
des gains mais il faudra faire les deux
on peut juste pas conserver les volumes
actuels
si on entend totalement décarbonés cette
production c'est vrai pour tous les
procédés industriels
sauf que si on fait moins de ciment bas
on va construire moins de logements
c'est absolument évident et on va
construire - deux bâtiments
donc la question c'est comment on gère
ça il semblerait j'ai pas vérifié les
chiffres mais il semblerait que depuis
très longtemps la grande bretagne
construisent beaucoup moins de logements
que la france chaque année
alors qu'elle a une population à peu
près identique donc on est en train
d'essayer de comprendre à quoi c'est dû
en tout cas je ne connaissais pas ce
j'ai appris ça y'a pas longtemps et si
c'est vrai donc ils en ont parlé vois
pas pourquoi je leur fais pas confiance
et bien c'est voilà une question
intéressante donc on voit bien que tout
ça est systémique
donc oui il faut décarbonés ciment et
décarbonées le ciment ça veut
probablement dire va construire et donc
comment sa chair il suffit pas de dire
on va on va tous conservés sur ça c'est
vraiment le problème de ce sujet
systémique
quelle énergie c'est que on touche pas
une brique quelque part sans que à ce
moment ça déstabilise l'édifice ailleurs
c'est toute la difficulté de réfléchir à
ce problème
alors après il ya une question sur les
engagements de l'union européenne
l'union européenne s'est engagée à
réduire ses émissions de 55 % d'ici à
2030 alors c'est à partir de 1990 1 on
est en mai 2021 en europe y aurait-il
des bons élèves qui auraient déjà établi
un plan d'action suffisamment détaillés
et chiffrés pour données complète
confiance que cet objectif pourrait être
atteint alors à ma connaissance non
alors je peux vous répondre pour la
france puisque pour la france il ya un
organisme qui a le mandat de répondre à
ces questions qui s'appelle le haut
conseil pour le climat donc il se trouve
que je suis un tout petit peu au courant
des travaux de cet organisme fils que
j'en fais partie et donc si vous suivez
un peu la production du haut conseil
pour le climat vous verrez que
à chaque fois qu'on sort un rapport ont
vite pour le moment on n'est pas dans
les clous alors on était déjà peint dans
les clous avec les -40%
donc on est encore moins dans les clous
avec les moins 55 donc la réponse est
non en ce moment est en train de se
discuter à l'assemblée nationale une loi
sur enfin va se disputer à l'assemblée
nationale une loi sur la
décentralisation
cette loi sur la décentralisation si
j'en crois les shifters qui l'ont qui
ont lu ses 850 pages je leur tire mon
chapeau parce que ça doit être moins
passionnant à lire qu'un un bon fred
vargas et bien y
le climat est totalement à côté des
mesures qui sont proposés c'est à dire
qu'il n'est juste pas intégré dans la
réflexion donc d'abord vous allez
commencer par dire aux élus fait comme
ceci fait comme seul à gérer l'urbanisme
comme ceux ci ne gérait pas comme cela
et c
puis un jour on vous dira tiens bien
merde j'ai oublié de leur pari qui va
dans cette histoire est bien qu'est ce
que je fais maintenant vous faites rien
ils font comme avant où ils font ce
qu'il faut pas donc le donc la réponse
est non il ya des grands discours
aujourd'hui sauf que quand on regarde en
pratique comment les choses se passent
les choses ne se passeront et je ne vois
pas de raison fondamentale de penser que
pour l'essentiel des pays européens qui
sont des démocraties et donc qu'ils sont
qui ont des modes de fonctionnement qui
doit pas être très très éloignées de ce
qu'on trouve en france j'ai pas de
raison de penser que c'est très
différent
pense que ça marche à peu près de la
même manière c'est à dire que vous avez
également des gouvernements qui traite
les trucs en silo avec des gens qui se
parlent peu et c'est débouclage
systémique qui sont pas faits s'il y
avait un pays à regarder ça serait la
grande bretagne 1 gb faire je vous
avouerai elle ne fait aujourd'hui plus
partie de l'union européenne donc je
sais pas comment il va se positionner
vis-à-vis de cet engagement de -55 mais
en attendant aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya
des pays qui ont un plan crédible pour y
arriver non est d'autant moins que comme
vous le savez tous les pays disent par
ailleurs qu'ils vont y arriver dans un
contexte de croissance économique hors
l'équation de kaya montre que marié la
croissance économique et pour ceux qui
connaissent pas l'équation de kaya il ya
une page sur mon site perso qui
s'appelle qu'est-ce que l'équation de
kaya ça vous donnera la règle du jeu est
bien l'équation de catherine ii 3
l'équation de kaya montre que de marier
la baisse des émissions de co2 et à
cause du rôle particulier de l'énergie
dans l'économie et la croissance
économique se rapproche de la quadrature
du cercle et du reste l' agence
européenne de l'environnement qui est
une des institutions officielles de
l'union comme la cour de justice ou la
commission et bien a émis un papier
enfin publié un papier en janvier
dernier dans lequel il est écrit que il
est extrêmement peu probable qu'on
arrive à marier la croissance économique
avec la diminution des pressions sur
l'environnement
donc c'est une institution officielle de
l'union qui le dit et ils ont publié ça
à peu près au même moment où la
commission parler de croissance verte
ce qui est assez rigolo j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de journalistes reprendre ce
papier
par contre ils ont tous continué à
parler de croissance et donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement on
continue à être dans l'illusion total
qui est qu' on va avoir à la fois la
croissance et la baisse forte des
émissions de co2 voire même l'un grâce à
l'autre car grâce à la croissance on
aura plein de moyens du coup on va
pouvoir investir partout et tout
décarbonée personnellement je suis
beaucoup plus complexe et donc je pense
que si on allait -55% ça se fera dans le
cadre d'une récession dont personne n'a
idée aujourd'hui est que si on n'est pas
dans le cas d'une récession dont
personne n'a idée au jour
malheureusement enfin pas les moins
c'est ce que je crois alors on fera
moins quelque chose quand même
c'est absolument évident mais le plan
structuré et systémique organisé qui
permet d'y arriver aujourd'hui n'existe
pas tout simplement parce que l'élément
climat n'est pas présent dans
l'essentiel des décisions que prennent
les gouvernements dans dans les secteurs
dont ils ont la charge alors un d une
des raisons à cela aussi est le manque
de compréhension de la part de la classe
politique du problème à traiter
pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui il ya
monsieur le maire qui a fait un post sur
l'hydrogène sur le fait qu'on habille
énergie observèrent soula bateau qui
fonctionne avec du photovoltaïque et qui
a une pile à combustible et on l'habille
sous la tour eiffel pour illuminer la
tour eiffel avec l'énergie avec
l'électricité produite par énergie
observèrent est alors bruno le maire de
s'extasier en disant ah c'est génial
c'est l'avènement de l'économie bas
carbone
alors j'ai fait un petit calcul d'ordre
de grandeur énergie observèrent produit
son électricité avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques ses 50 grammes de co2
par kilowattheure une fois que vous avez
électrolyse lots et vous avez compressé
l'hydrogène derrière surtout sur
l'électrolyseur d'énergie observeur qui
doit pas être qui est un petit
électrolyseur qui doit être optimale en
termes de rendement il vous reste la
moitié donc vous êtes à 100 grammes de
co2 par kilowattheure d'hydrogène que
vous avez récupéré après vous fait
passer ça dans une pile à combustible
pour faire de l'électricité et à ce
moment vous êtes à 200 grammes de co2
par kilowattheure électrique qui en sort
donc la tour eiffel est illuminé grâce à
nrj observeur avec du kilowattheure
électrique à 200 grammes de co2 alors
que en ce moment le réseau et à 20 je
regardais pas plus tard que ce matin sur
rtl
donc en fait ce décarbonés et dix fois
plus carbonées que l'électricité de
réseau voilà donc cessé alors bon j'ai
rien j'ai pas de dents particulièrement
monsieur le maire je suis juste en train
de dire
c'est un exemple que je prends pour
montrer qu'aujourd'hui un des obstacles
aussi à faire des plans crédibles
en ce qui concerne la décarbonation de
l'économie est tout simplement le fait
que les gens qui s'occupent d'économie
non essentiellement pas de compréhension
non pas de compréhension suffisante sur
la physique sous jacente et les enjeux
sous jacents
quand on parle de changement climatique
et quand on parle d'énergie
donc du coup ils peuvent pas prendre des
mesures pertinentes ne serait ce que
parce que ils comprennent pas le
problème
il croit comprendre peut-être je sais
pas le problème en question parce que
pour en revenir à la question par
laquelle j'ai ouvert cette petite
discussion exactement ce long monologue
et bien est-ce que encore les gens vous
disent comprendre oui oui les la seule
fois dans ma vie où je me suis venu j'ai
vu monsieur le maire en face à face
j'étais pas seulement voilà cette fois
de ma vie où j'ai eu en face à face
il tenait le discours de quelqu'un qui
disait j'ai parfaitement bien compris et
je vais m'occuper du problème donc voilà
donc est ce que ça veut dire qu'il a
tout bien compris je ne sais pas en tout
cas il ya un vrai sujet de compréhension
est ce que cette compréhension les
meilleurs dans d'autres pays
probablement est-ce qu'elle est parfaite
dans certains pays
je ne crois pas enfin vous savez
donnerait est ce que c'est un
déterminant de l'action pertinente
assurément est-ce qu'elle garantit la
surréaction pertinente non parce que
nous restons en démocratie et donc en
démocratie si l'électeur avait un truc
con même si la personne enfin un truc
qu'on veut quelque chose qui ne résout
pas le problème
c'est à dire qu'on est bien est ce que
l'élu qui lui même a bien compris que ce
n'était pas pertinent s'empêcherait de
l'appliquer absolument pas regardez
madame merkel qui a très bien compris ce
qu'elle faisait quand elle a décidé de
supprimer le nucléaire en allemagne
parce qu'à titre personnel elles
pensaient que c'était une ânerie elle
l'a fait quand même donc le voilà donc
cesser tout ça est une équation
compliquée et on en revient toujours et
encore au même point de départ qui est
en démocratie c'est pas les élus qu'il
faut convaincre ans et l'électorat et
donc c'est vraiment ça le sujet donc les
ai donc les pays pour finir de répondre
à la question feront un plan crédible
sur la baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre le jour où non seulement
eux ont compris les contreparties mais
le jour
où l'électorat aura compris et
contrepartie et ça me renvoie aussi à
une partie de ce que j'ai répondu au
début de ce monologue donc qui était qu
aujourd'hui les décideurs qui ont bien
compris que de respecter les limites
planétaires c'était la fin de la
croissance
et bien il y en a pas tant que ça mais
c'est avec ces gens-là qu'on peut
commencer à discuter et il faut que
l'électorat comprennent ça aussi et
accepte de négocier sur ces bases
après les vraies questions difficiles
comment derrière comment est-ce que là
dedans je le redis on change totalement
de paradigme et pour autant on n'est pas
désespérée comment est-ce que les gens
n'ont pas le sentiment d'être ceux qui
font le plus d'efforts au détriment
enfin alors que d'autres en font moins
que c'est la question du partage de
l'effort et de l'équité c'est essentiel
quand on commence à transpirer fois
c'est ça les questions qui sont
importantes et c'est mais c'est des
questions qu'on peut commencer à traiter
qu'une fois que l'on s'est accordé sur
la contre partie essentielle de la
sphère qui est qu'il ya plus de
croissance et donc ce il ce postulat là
aujourd'hui il est quasiment intégré par
aucun élu et aucun décideur à commencer
par les décideurs européens alors
qu'est-ce que j'ai d'autres après allez
on va encore prendre une deux questions
qui ont obtenu à nantes il ya une
question qui a obtenu 35 points quel
serait selon vous les actions à mettre
en place rapidement au niveau du
numérique et de l'informatique
alors que la réponse elle est dans le
rapport
enfin elle et elle est pour partie
pardon dans les rapports qui ont sorti
le shift project sur le numérique alors
je rappelle quelques quelques évidences
d'abord je tire les oreilles de tous
ceux qui me regardent
en d'autre chose que du 144 pixels par
pouce je vous préviens j'ai les noms
[Musique]
parce que c'est en gros aujourd'hui la
vidéo en ligne
donc ce que je suis en train de faire là
typiquement géante ou cachés sous la
vidéo en ligne
c'est 75% ou 80 % de l'accroissement des
usages d'internet c'est ça c'est ça qui
tirent très très fortement la hausse
la hausse de l' usap l'internet cette
vidéo en ligne se répartit en gros en
quatre morceaux incarcés netflix un car
c'est le porno incarcéré youtube et un
car c'est tout le reste dont ce que je
suis en train de faire en ce moment
et puis après je passerai sur youtube où
je contribuerai
à l'autre car et si j'en prends mes
détracteurs ce que je dis est tellement
grossier que peut-être on pourra ranger
dans la catégorie porno je ne sais pas
le donc la priorité des priorités c'est
d'arrêter l'inflation à l'augmentation
du flux de données ce qui par ailleurs a
un effet de bord majeur c'est que ça
augmente la puissance des data center et
la consommation des datacenters et 20 %
de l'empreinte carbone du numérique ça
augmente la rotation de des équipements
parce qu'il faut des équipements de plus
en plus puissants pour se servir de
cette de ce surplus d'image et la
fabrication de nos terminaux
c'est de mémoire de l'ordre de 5 ans que
45% n'ont appelé les composants rideau
la danse avec 40% de des émissions ont
donc tv écrans de smartphones donc en
gros si l'arrêté l'inflation tout ça
alors quelles sont les mesures qui
peuvent le permettre
où il y en a deux ou trois très
concrètes la première c'est d'allonger
la durée légale de garantie des objets
numériques
si l'ordinateur que je suis en train
d'utiliser sa durée légale de garantie
passe à 10 ans et ça je pense que c'est
à la main de l'état eh bien ça veut dire
que le constructeur qui me l'a vendu
si son appareil tombe en panne avant dix
ans parce qu'il se dit comme ça
d'habitude dès que la durée légale de
garantie est passé voir l'assurance pour
les trois ans et bien craque
il va être obligé d'en racheter un
nouveau parce que toute façon il peut
pas faire sans et bien ce qui avant
était une source de profit de lille
charge puisque j'en achèterais pas un
nouveau je demanderai la réparation de
l'ancien aux frais du constructeur
donc là ça veut dire que vous
ralentissez fortement la rotation du
parc d'appareils
alors évidemment apple va faire la
gueule et sa capitalisation autant les
fonds de pension américains qui sont
investis chez apple tout autant mais par
contre
saab et sera l'empreinte carbone du
numérique la deuxième chose qu'on peut
faire c'est mettre les opérateurs sous
contrainte d'empreinte carbone pour le
raccorder les fréquences parce que une
bonne partie de l'empreinte carbone
passe par les réseaux sans fil donc la
fibre optique
ça va à peu près par contre la 4g et
plus encore la 5g ça va beaucoup moins
la consommation énergétique par ko
transférer beaucoup plus élevé et donc
on pourrait c'est une proposition que le
haut conseil pour le climat a fait et
c'est une proposition qui a été reprise
par la loi qui vient d'être votée au
sénat dire à l'arcep donc à l'organisme
de régulation des télécoms vous autres
vous autorisez les licences aux
opérateurs sous condition que leur
empreinte carbone baisse en accord avec
la snb c'est donc la caille stratégie
nationale bas carbone de 1 2 3 4 5 % par
an et si ils font pas ça va craquer
voulant retirer la licence donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui serait très utile
parce que en fait dans le numérique
malheureusement ou heureusement je ne
sais pas
le système est très attiré par une
politique de l'offre c'est-à-dire une
fois que l'offre existe tous autant que
nous sommes vous noie tout le monde on
est quand même des ados attardés une
fois que le machin existe on a quand
même vachement de mal à passer au dessus
donc en fait le seul manière de faire en
sorte qu'on se lit vite c'est que
l'offre n'existe pas et qu'on se dise
tous collectivement elles avancent très
bien regarder les points donnés de
jancovici ont un peu plus haute
définition je vois pas ce que ça va
amener ça c'est sûr que ça va rien vous
amener donc c'est pas utile
d'aller vers ça et donc on s'en passera
et puis on sera heureux d'entendre chose
en mangeant les frais ce qu'il en reste
donc le pardon c'est pas des poils qui
me démangent donc le le sujet est
vraiment d'essayer d'avoir une
limitation un peu centralisée au niveau
2 au niveau de l'offre et il faut agir
sur deux ou trois composantes j'ai envie
de dire le problème et est désagréable
enfin où les réponses sont désagréables
justement parce que le problème est
assez simple le problème assez simple
c'est qu'il faut limiter la bande
passante limitée la rotation des
équipements et collet l'a contrainte à
ceux qui la maîtrisent
c'est à dire les opérateurs les
opérateurs et les constructeurs
on pourrait aussi imaginer une taxe
carbone sur numérique etc
mais enfin bon là le temps qu'on arrive
à mettre ça en place on sera tout à fait
tout à fait débordée par le sujet alors
j'ajoute que il ya un autre élément qui
est majeur à mon avis à avoir en tête
dans cette affaire qui est un élément de
résilience aujourd'hui il ne vous
échappera pas surtout qu'en ce moment
c'est l'époque que l'état est devenu un
foutu d'assurer sa fonction la plus
régaliennes qui est de lever l'impôt
sans les gars ça c'est à dire que alors
moi je suis dans un département où ce
n'est pas encore fait donc je m'apprête
à faire ma déclaration d'impôts
je vais faire ça par internet c'est à
dire par les cafards je vais utiliser un
ordinateur qui est fabriqué par les
gaffes à je vais utiliser un système
d'exploitation qui est fabriqué par les
cafards je vais utiliser internet qui
est gérée par les gars phare pour me
connecter au site du ministère des
finances est par ailleurs mon ordinateur
aura été fabriqués alors par avec des
gars femmes et avec les équivalents
taiwan dauchy loin ou sinon taïwanais
c'est à dire les fabricants de puces et
les fabricants de microprocesseurs donc
aujourd'hui le fonctionnement de notre
pays est totalement dépendant je dis
bien totalement dépendant d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs
externes qui sont ceux qui fabriquent
les puces les ordinateurs et qui font
fonctionner système et qui fabrique des
logiciels d'exploitation on est pieds et
poings liés avec ces gens là donc on a
un autre suggéré sur le numérique qui
est un sujet de souveraineté alors ou
bien on considère que ça nous va très
bien d'avoir été entre guillemets
vassaliser de fait parce que finalement
le vassal il est sous la protection de
son seigneur peut-être que c'est pas une
si mauvaise qui a intérêt à le garder
dans son champ l'influencent on peut
être que finalement c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'on joue quand on devient une province
américaines ou chinoises n'étaient pas
ou bien on décide que c'est pas
exactement ça quand on a envie et alors
la radio et pas de vérité scientifique
là dedans c'est une affaire de
préférence et à ce moment on a quand
même un peu de grattage de tête à faire
sur la question de est ce que le système
actuellement est satisfaisant est ce
qu'il est satisfaisant qu'il ya un
producteur de puces taïwanais qui
lorsqu'il a des problèmes pour produire
notamment à cause d'une sécheresse
cammas et les voilà le climat s'invite à
nouveau dans la partie face qu'on
commence à avoir des problèmes
d'approvisionnement sur la construction
des voitures en france et plus largement
est ce que les pouvoirs réels qui
exercent ces gens là sur une société qui
est devenue totalement incapable de
fonctionner sans numérique certains
numérique aujourd'hui vous payez plus
vos achats voulu communiquer plus avec
personne il n'ya plus d'organisation des
transports il aurait rien à lui dire
s'est il ya même plus la procédure de
backup sur papier c'est fini je veux
dire le
c'est fini on peut parvenir à
l'impression de billets papier pour
compenser le fait que les ordinateurs
bancaire disparaîtrait et comptabilisé à
la main toutes les opérations
aujourd'hui les ordinateurs comptabilise
automatiquement on peut plus il y en a
trop bon donc aujourd'hui un crack
numérique ou un crack d'internet c'est
quelque chose qui est bon je vous
apprends rien je veux dire la
cybersécurité c'est un enjeu et c'est
peut-être que je suis en temps d'évoquer
n'arrive à part j'en sais rien en tout
cas il semble que là le sujet
environnemental et le sujet résilience
vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre de deux
éléments indispensables dont on ne
connaît pas bien la pérennité sûr je
sais ça que c'est pour ça que je voulais
que je voulais conclure alors après dans
les autres questions indications sur le
stockage dédié aux sources d'énergies
intermittentes ça devait répondre
rapidement parce que c'est assez facile
de répondre rapidement
aujourd'hui vous avez dans le monde
alors je suis désolé pour ceux qui ont
déjà entendu ce calculateur de vendeurs
il ya un peu plus de 7000 gigawatts de
puissance électrique installée ces
terres si vous regardez la totalité des
moyens de production qui sont installés
dans le monde vous avez un peu plus de
7000 milliards de watts de puissance de
production électrique vous avez un peu
plus de deux pour cent de cette
puissance de production qui est de la
puissance de stockage c'est à dire que
vous avez 260 gigawatts en gros 170
watts de puissance de stockage c'est à
dire que en gros à un instant donné
il n'y a que 2 % de la production qui
peut être stockée c'est ça que ça veut
dire
dans le monde dans son ensemble au sein
de ses 2 % vous en avez moins de 1% qui
est constitué de batterie le reste c'est
essentiellement des barrages réversible
on a en france par exemple barre
devant maison donc c'est un barrage dans
lequel vous avez un réservoir à la main
un réservoir la balle et le réservoir à
l'âme on laisse filer de locon turbines
quand on s'en sert comme barrage et
quand on veut s'en servir pour stocker à
ce moment on reprend l'eau dans le
réservoir à la vallée avec une pompe
utilisant l'électricité qu'on a en trop
prof
on le remonte dans le réservoir à
l'avant alors c'est ça qui fait
l'essentiel de la puissance de stockage
sur terre pour 2%
je le répète de la puissance de
production électrique donc même sans
parler des patries aujourd'hui on serait
totalement incapable d'avoir un système
de stockage permettant d'avoir que des
éoliennes et les panneaux solaires
c'est donc il faudrait rajouter les
batteries alors avec la totalité du
lithium disponibles sur terre j'ai il ya
un ingénieur du cio a qui avait fait le
calcul que l'on pourrait stocker
quelques jours de production électrique
sur terre je dis bien quelques jours de
production électrique sur terre
donc on n'est pas du tout dans les
ordres de grandeur qui pérorent rta
sortie il ya pas longtemps un rapport
montrant que en france pour pallier la
variabilité interannuelle du climat
alors c'est quoi la variabilité
interannuelle du climat c'est le fait
que la quantité totale de vent n'est pas
constante d'une année sur l'autre il ya
des années avec beaucoup de vent des
années - devant il ya des années avec
beaucoup de soleil et des années avec
moins de soleil et alors si vous
palucher une année avec que des hivers
grille mais anticyclonique et peu
ventées versus aider et aigri versus
pourquoi vous avez en gros entre 10 et
20 % de différence de production donc ça
voudrait dire qu'il faut stocker entre
10 et 20% de la production du d'année
d'une année sur l'autre pour être
capable de pallier la variabilité
interannuelle des sources intermittentes
et fatale si vous êtes capable de
stocker trois jours de production sur
batterie ben vous voyez que le compte
n'y est pas du tout donc l'idée qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser des batteries pour
créer un système produisant autant que
d'électricité qu'aujourd'hui et en stock
en tout sur batterie est à mon avis
totalement hors d'atteinte je dis -
minimes et enfants ne verront jamais ça
ni mes petits enfants et pour en revenir
à de l'électricité purement stockées sur
batterie en gros ça veut dire qu'il
faudra diviser la quantité totale
d'électricité qu'on utilise dans le
monde par un facteur de plusieurs
dizaines de producteurs combien je
préfère les calculs mais ça me paraît
être ça le bonheur de vendeurs donc
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir en tête a donc
ça veut dire quelques dizaines de fois
des machines électriques en moins pour
nous et donc moins de toutes les
machines qu'on aime bien aujourd'hui les
ascenseurs les laminoirs girouard trouvé
moins de tout ce à quoi je parle pas
juste des cafetières électriques et les
radiateurs et des robots chirurgicaux et
les roulettes en dentiste ce qui est
donc le l'idée que les batteries vont
être un déterminant significatif de la
transition des systèmes électriques vers
du renouvelable et du stockage à titre
personnel j'ai des doutes si on voulait
vraiment faire du stockage massif il
faudrait faire des stocks de manière
massive alors on pourra éventuellement
là aussi j'ai fait des petits calculs
d'or de vendeurs on pourrait imaginer
par exemple reste à se mettre d'accord
avec les suisses que la totalité de
l'eau du léman sert de réservoir aval et
on doit la totalité des vallées qui sont
autour du léman la totalité pour
remonter de l'eau quand il ya du vent et
du soleil en excès et voilà on pourrait
faire ça après la question est de savoir
si on pense que environnementalement
c'est beaucoup mieux qu un système dans
lequel on a dû nucléaire puisque c'est
le seul bas carbone pilotable par
l'hydroélectricité
voilà c'est ça le sait sur la question
ma réponse vous la connaissez c'est non
s'il ya des gens qui pensent que oui
parle il faut discuter
mais mais mais sur batterie physiquement
j'ai vraiment beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
alors après qu'est-ce que j'ai l'autre
je regarde toujours les suis désolé je
pourrais pas répondre à toutes les
questions
parce qu'il y en a trop donc je réponds
à celle je suis le démago - à celles qui
ont eu beaucoup de beaucoup de beaucoup
de d'après sylvain commentaires
d'engagement dans le monde i like et
donc j'avais encore un truc là qui
m'avait que j'avais vu passer isolation
des bâtiments
on parle beaucoup d'isolation des
bâtiments pour en réduire la
consommation d'énergie mais beaucoup de
matériaux utilisés sont très énergivores
et c est il viable possible pertinent
d'avoir une plus forte utilisation de
matériaux biosourcés dans un monde où on
approche les 8 milliards d'âmes
alors la réponse est ça c'est que en
fait oui la fabrication des matériaux
d'isolation non bio forcé et énergivores
mais le temps de retour énergétique de
ces matériaux c'est à dire l'énergie que
ça permet et qui est une énergie fossile
souvent pour les maisons en tout cas
chauffer enfin pour les logements
chauffés au gaz et au fioul
le temps de retour énergétique de ces
matériaux est assez faible en fait quand
vous regardez c'est souvent de l'ordre
de l'année voilà voire moins donc en
gros ça reste quand même
macroscopiquement une bonne affaire
d'isoler même avec des matériaux qui
sont non bio sourcés alors si en plus on
peut les bio sourcés c'est bien mais les
bio sourcés renvoie à la question que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure une question
pas simple qui est la concurrence
d'usagé des sols entre le matériau
l'énergie la biodiversité et
l'alimentation alors east et les
infrastructures humaines historiquement
c'est la biodiversité qui a gagné la
partie c'est à dire que quand les hommes
étaient très très peu nombreux
là
l'idée de leur agriculture plus leur
infrastructure plus le bois qu'ils
utilisaient comme matériau d'oeuvre plus
le bois qu'ils utilisaient pour fournir
de l'énergie
tout ça était petit devant la quantité
totale de forêt qu'il y avait alors que
je dis historiquement enfin ça c'est il
ya quelques il ya deux ans à venir
il ya deux siècles c'était déjà plus
rien le minimum forestier en europe
c'est édifiant 50 mais donc on retombe
dans un cas particulier et donc après il
faut faire des calculs dans de grandeur
que je confesse ne pas avoir fait c'est
à dire si on voulait en france isoler un
million de logements par an avec des
matériaux biosourcés qu'est-ce que ça
demanderait comme surfaces dédiées à la
production du matériau qui permet de
faire les isolants biosourcés et je dois
dire que comme je n'ai pas fait de
calculs
malheureusement je n'ai pas de réponse à
vous donner le donc peut-être que ça
paraisse peut-être que ça passe par âge
c'est la seule chose qui est sûre c'est
que si ça ne passe qu'en faisant de la
déforestation alors là il vaut mieux les
utiliser des isolants millions là y'a
juste pas photo c'est absolument évident
et ça peut même se poser cette question
si on a comme arbitrage
d'un côté je crée des forêts en
croissance et j'utilise du gaz pour
faire des matériaux minéraux et de
l'autre côté je n'utilise pas le gaz
pour faire des matériaux minéraux mais
je ne laisse pas ma forêt croître et
donc mon stock de carbone croître et
bien même là il faut faire des calculs
parce que c'est pas évident que on n'est
pas intérêt à utiliser des matériaux
minéraux et non pas bio sourcés pour
pour faire cette isolation voilà donc je
j'ai envie de dire la réponse est une
réponse de méthode
aujourd'hui comme j'ai pas fait le
calcul alors j'espère que s'il ya des
collaborateurs à 44 qu'ils ont fait ils
m'en voudront pas de dire que je ne sais
pas quand je devrais savoir mais met en
colère à titre personnel je le calcul je
les ai pas vus donc je me suis pas
capable de répondre à cette question
voilà voilà
eh bien écoutez vu l'heure je pense que
on s'approche de la fin ale est ce que
j'ai une j'ai une dernière question là
donc je me dis allez celle là je m'en
fiche
personne ne l'a aimée mais moi il me
plaît à s'il y en a une qui me plaît bah
voilà est-ce que la mise à la règle
contre 1 des machines par manque de
croquettes c'est-à-dire par manque
d'énergie permettra-t-elle de remettre
tout le monde au travail et d'endiguer
définitivement le chômage alors la
réponse est à terme oui
à court terme c'est l'effet exactement
inverse
pourquoi est-ce qu'à court terme c'est
l'effet exactement inverse parce que
aujourd'hui dans le monde dans lequel
nous sommes
l'essentiel des emplois sont devenus d
emploi d'auxiliaire de la machine alors
je vais commencer par moi je suis un
auxiliaire de la machine sans ordinateur
je ne pourrais pas manié de tableur
excel de powerpoint etc
quand je pourrai pas faire le consultant
du reste dans un monde sans match il n'y
avait pas de consultants donc je suis un
enfant de l'énergie abondante alors que
en apparence je fais un truc
dématérialisée voyez je suis dans un
bureau ça fume pas il n'y a rien qui
fait du bruit
y'a rien qui émet de la fumée voilà tout
est immobile à part moi dans ce bureau
en fait non malheureusement consultance
et c'est un métier au niveau auquel il
est actuellement aujourd'hui c'est
malheureusement un métier d'auxiliaire
de la machine après c'est vrai pour je
peux prendre tous les gens d'aujourd'hui
vous voyez
ce matin je suis allé au marché acheter
quelques folies et bien tous les gens
qui étaient là étaient des auxiliaires
de la machine des commerçants sont venus
en camion ils ont vendu des fruits qui
ont été récoltés par des tracteurs qui
ont été acheminés aussi par des camions
ils m'ont donné ça dans des pochons en
papier qui ont été fabriqués par des
machines
donc en fait ces gens sont tous des
auxiliaires de la machine qui est ici
j'avais un robot intelligent pour le
prendre les trucs sur les étalages à la
limite le commerçant alors il serait
beaucoup moins drôle des robots mais les
commerçants seraient pas utiles si je
supprime les machines donc là imaginons
que pour mon commerçant je supprime les
camions est-ce que ça va remplacer
instantanément mon commerçant part il va
il part dans le sud-ouest chercher ou
dans le sud-est chercher les cerises un
sac sont pas gelés et y en a un je peux
vous dire j'en ai acheté ce matin et ils
les amènent à dos d'homme jusqu'à là où
j'habite
pour les ventes non non pas du tout il
fait faillite donc en fait alors une
manière plus j'ai envie de 10 ans
sortait donc plus orthodoxes de dire la
même chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui de
différentiel de productivité entre la
machine et l'homme est telle et telle
que si vous supprimez une machine vous
ne crée par un emploi à la place pour
remplacer la racine il faudrait créer
des milliers des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois à la place et en l'occurrence
là pour remplacer un camion pour ceux
d'entre vous qui connaissent
l'équivalence à un moteur de camion ses
puissants comme 4000 paires de jambes
bon et ça et même 4000 paires de jambes
puissantes vont pas aussi vite que un
camion qui est censée ne pas dépasser
les 90 sur autoroute qui dépassent
souvent et les 80 pleine charge qui
dépasse tout le temps mais la paire de
jambes 80 km heure
j'en parlais pas beaucoup donc le
tout cas pas sur quelques centaines de
kilomètres donc là là donc ce qui va se
passer c'est que si vous supprimez de
camions vous n'allez pas le remplacer
par une de 5 personnes vous allez devoir
le remplacer par des milliers de
porteurs voir si vous voulez assurer le
même délit comme ils vont moins
lentement comme ils n'ont plus lentement
pardon c'est porter par des dizaines de
milliers de personnes
et à ce moment le coût du transport il
n'augmente pas de 20% il augmente de
quelques milliers et ça devient
insupportable pour le système économique
et donc vous n'avez pas la substitution
de la machine par l'homme vous avez
l'art et du flux et l'arrêt des emplois
qui sont associées aux flux et cet
exemple que je viens de prendre je
pourrais le prendre pour n'importe quel
autre emploi un emploi de vendeur dans
un magasin de centre lille
donc quand je vais non pas au marché à
côté de chez moi
mais au supermarché à côté du bureau
c'est exactement pareil c'est des
auxiliaires de la machine c'est des
auxiliaires des camions qui sont du
livre et cd c'est pas péjoratif de dire
ça un jeu puisque encore une fois même
moi je suis un auxiliaire de la machine
mais moins moi aussi a pas de même donc
si je suis un client de la machine donc
nous sommes tous des auxiliaires de la
machine et encore une fois la puissance
de la machine
comparé à la puissance de l'homme est
tellement supérieur que si je supprime
une machine tout ce que je fais c'est
que je supprime l'emploi associés mais
j'en crée pas d'autres en face voilà
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle à
court terme
malheureusement supprimer des machines
ça crée pas de l'emploi et c'est la
raison pour laquelle bc
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
manière subi ça ne crée pas de l'emploi
parce qu'on remplace les gens par les
machines
ça supprime des flux physiques dont
dépendent des emplois et donc ça
supprime les emplois
c'est la raison pour laquelle bc
l'approvisionnement énergétique à court
terme c'est récessif et ça crée du
chômage au lieu de deux comme on
pourrait l'espérer
parce que c'était ça le sens de cette
question crée de l'emploi en
remplacement de la machine c'est bien
tout le problème
voilà et sur cette question du coeur
puisque c'était la dernière on a
allez je décide qu'il est l'heure de
passer à table pour ceux d'entre vous
qui sont dans le fuseau horaire français
est qui et qui décide de se sustenter ou
en tout cas qui ont décidé d'arrêter
enfin d'attendre la fin de ce truc là
pour les sustenter ce qui est au moins
mon cas et le la machine en version
illustrée sortira le 15 octobre donc là
maintenant je peux vous l'annoncer donc
la bd que je suis en train de finir avec
christophe blain et dont nous avons
trouvé la fin donc on a fait le plus dur
enfin trouvé la manière dont ça devait
se terminer doit sortir le 15 octobre et
donc iron man ou le verrez qu être voilà
et bien écoutez
merci à celles et ceux qui ont été
patients jusqu'à maintenant ou en tout
cas qui ont attendu la fin je ne sais
pas si on est en route
et puis pour ceux du fuseau horaire
français pas de soirée et pour ceux des
autres fuseau horaire bonne journée puis
déjeuné juste pourquoi pas de lui et à
une prochaine fois peut-être un au
revoir comme disait l'autre